[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous mesdames et messieurs on
arrive pile à l'heure parce qu'on
discutait échec avec Baki
qui va arriver
forcément tu mets tu mets deux joueurs
d'échec ensemble même si on est arrivé
bien en avance on discute trop échec
c'est terrible mais on bouffe de la
tropézienne aussi donc on est très bien
donc dixième partie je vois qu'il y a
une petite faute on a tout mis à jour
les caméras qui partent pas pour le
moment
ça retourne dans l'anglaise
5 d'accord donc c'était sa prépa
quand il avait décidé c'était quoi ronde
un peu plus pour profiter de l'état de
mes formes de Ding à ce moment-là et
retomber sur des variantes un peu plus
forcées avec ces quatre six aujourd'hui
mais ok joue ces quatre cinq ça c'est
une grosse grosse ligne en ce moment
4 ouais beaucoup oh il est fou c'est 5
alors ça je vais te dire j'ai joué c'est
Mathieu qui m'avait préparé ça en
2014-2015 et j'avais battu tabacabaye
avec cavalier Provin qui a gagné les
Grands Prix cavaliers prank donc ça va
être une belle ligne D4 foubeccat puis
on prend le 5 cavalier Pro 4 dame F3
cavalier prend ces trois pions prend C3
fou c'est 5 dam G3 et à l'époque qui va
aller prendre 5 et D4 c'était plus ou
moins nouveau
donc Mathieu a trouvé une fourchette
quoi et donc ça joue cette légumes à
noter que sur E4 sur 4 4 le plus à la
mode en ce moment c'est fou B4 plutôt
que fou C5 je crois qu'on en a parlé de
ça dans un live nous a nous a parlé de
ça mais fou C5 ça va sur des variantes
plus forcées et fubécase sur un jeu plus
alors attends on va on va on va demander
dans le chat
2014 ou 2015 on va ouvrir le chat on va
leur demander si c'est dans les fameuses
prépas lichess
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est le coup de Mathieu
je crois que c'est le coup que j'avais
joué fou ces cinq fouettes je sais plus
exactement donc ça c'était contre tu vas
regarder
j'allais turbines quand même
donc on va en profiter
qui se met un petit peu de côté
hyper asymétrique comme position nous
dit mastrolog dans le chat et ouais
c'est mais c'est des belles positions
quand tu dois revenir au score tu es
content quand même avec les Blancs
d'avoir ça
est-ce que je sais pas parce que comme
c'est très forcé ah tu veux dire que tu
peux peut-être te faire en fait il
aurait bien aimé de jouer les lignes à
la mode comme j'ai dit avec fub4 plutôt
que fou c'est 5 parce que on a vu que
depuis le début du match c'est ce qu'il
essaie de trouver avec les Blancs et
c'est ce que Yann arrive pas à voir des
lignes forcées quoi avec les noirs pour
ce que Yann il est très bon avec les
Blancs par exemple dans la dernière
espagnol même si c'est à peu près égal
plus en défense dans ce match en tout
cas
issu avec les Noirs dans des enfin à
part celle où il a joué H3 mais les deux
trois dernières il a un petit peu
est dans dans les fameuses bases
litchess
et ça nous intéresse en fait de savoir
si ça a été joué dans les parties
d'entraînement parce que ça nous
donnerait une information capitale donc
on a besoin du chat là un petit peu faut
travailler il y a plus Vlad donc on sait
plus et avant on savait en fait on avait
du Vlad mais là on ne sait plus
d'ailleurs Vlad magnifique il est parti
ok avis il nous a pas envoyé un message
rien en fait
on sait même pas si il est arrivé on
sait rien quoi juste il est parti
[Musique]
chez moi
[Rires]
pour la Coupe du Monde
il est peut-être chez moi en fait
qu'est-ce qui compense la facblissement
de la structure de pions on nous demande
dans le chat bah écoute simple à
t'expliquer déjà l'espace parce que tu
vois qu'il y a un pion E5 quand même qui
prend des cases dans le camp adverse et
le développement admettons tu fais dam
G3 bah tu tapes le pion petit rat qui a
déjà fou H6 qui fait mal qui gagne une
cale tu t'es obligé de jouer G6 donc ça
tu peux pas donc tu vas devoir jouer roi
et fuite forcer et ici fou et deux fois
F4 ou des trois ou moi j'aurais fout des
trois personnellement et que tu vas OK
et roi H1 et F4 tu as simplement un
avantage d'espace et développement
en contrepartie 21 pourrie
et encore 1194 parties litchi après
pousser ça hein mais ce qu'on veut
savoir c'est si elle est fameuse partie
du fameux pseudo en fait
il y avait que du damso ou du G3 dans
les parties de la base glitch et ben
voilà merci Ted rugbnal ça pourrait
mériter un VIP des infos comme ça oui
donc E4 c'était ouais bon par contre
Foussais 5 c'est un coup très rare donc
si
la en fait s'ils ont décidé de changer à
cause de slick au dernier moment c'est
possible qu'ils aient pas trop trop
regardé c'est 5
il y a eu 45 kerwana avec X5 c'est la
partie de vous devez vous en souvenir
c'est parti fameuse de 2019 du Grand
Swiss là où ils ont fait nul à maman une
partie un peu bizarre je pense que tu
avais fait la partie incroyable cette
partie
et fou et 7 sinon c'est aussi plus jouer
avec vous ces cinq coups c'est 5 c'est
très rare ça a été joué
donc il est prêt là aujourd'hui Yann
alors est-ce que c'est possible essaye
de se rappeler ou tu pourras mon avis là
il sait juste pas bah il va jouer dame
chez toi mais alors a priori
donc c'est possible de pas regarder un
coup comme fou c'est ça de pas trop
surtout si c'est au dernier moment quoi
parce que c'est vrai que dame j'ai trois
rois F8 tu dis oui bon en fait on peut
pas faire petit rock c'est un peu
d'ailleurs et moi j'ai joué tabac à Baye
donc il y a une dizaine d'années il
était pas si fort que maintenant il
avait peut-être 2350 mais il allait être
maître rapidement après ça après
beaucoup grande réflexion il avait joué
fou et 7 au lieu de fouet 5 donc quand
tu as pas si tu veux quand tu as pas sur
l'échiquier c'est hyper dur il avait
joué cette dame G3 petit rock on peut
peut-être le mettre
et ici juste donner la qualité faut
aussi G6 faut prendre la fuite parce que
sur l'échiquier ça lui paraissait très
dur en fait ok là c'est un peu mieux
pour les blancs il y a quand même des
compensations grâce aux à la structure
de pion ok le foot casse noire et tout
mais c'est clairement nette avantage non
oui un tel que ta bataille avait joué
c'est très dur ouais mais c'est si tu
connais pas c'est très dur à jouer
comment ne pas connaître
à l'époque 4 c'était vraiment parce que
c'est quand même bizarre comme coup
quand on regarde mais tu te rappelles la
première partie quand il y a joué le fou
français 6
faut prendre ces 6 décès dans l'espagnol
que personne connaissait
comme ça et oui ils vont dire Rennes
incroyable de pas connaître mais oui
mais c'est dur ouais mais quand on a des
positions qu'on a jamais joué c'est
toujours
surtout quand on est un peu sous
pression comme ça j'espère que tu es
content j'ai mis donc Kevin Bordy lui
dit stream en dessous et toi Etienne
Bacro j'ai mis le B
[Musique]
j'espère que ça te fait plaisir on l'a
fait remarquer dans le chat
c'est beau
on veut faire un genre de d'imitation
avec Fab si on trouve un kimono
il manque alpha échec.fr non
comme tu l'as pas
activé
de chasse.com d'ailleurs sur Twitter il
y a quelqu'un qui a écrit que
vraiment un génie le gars qui a fait ça
Eric c'est incroyable en fait il a
acheté le nom de domaine pour 55000
dollars il y a 20 ans mais ça c'était
notre faute
quelqu'un le trouvera dans le dans le
chat il y a un cereed sur Twitter hyper
intéressant mais le gars est vraiment
enfin très très fort en fait parce qu'il
a compris dès 2003
il y a pas par exemple le point fr ça
enfin il y a pas d'autres points comme
quoi il y a que le mais il a il a
compris qu'il fallait organiser les
échecs qu'il fallait l'organiser des
communautés
à l'époque tu vois non mais c'est bien
fait et puis en plus ok le nom est juste
fantastique
il a joué ou pas non non ils sont là
[Musique]
probable ouais mais c'est ce qui se
passe OK il avait prévu des choses qui
peut pas jouer grâce à sleek et au
dernier moment même s'ils sont plusieurs
à travailler ok je trouvais du monde ça
se prépare ils avaient fait une prépa
fantastique quand même ce qu'ils ont
moins de moyens clairement que Yann
et ils ont eu moins de temps parce que
Yann il se prépare depuis 2 ans avec
puis avec avec une équipe
énorme
de jouer les parties sur le litchess
elle est
colossale c'est incroyable c'est juste
incroyable mais comment ça a pu arriver
un truc pareil j'arrive pas à comprendre
bon bah ils sont pas
tu avais sardache dans le dans le chat
dans la ronde précédente avant-hier
avant hier et
ils disent un truc incroyable c'est que
même nous pour le pop-champ on avait
fait attention ouais ouais mais là
même pour un truc comme le Pocket un
truc d'amateur de streamer et tout on a
des millions il a fait la même erreur
aussi
[Musique]
de la caméra il est incroyable enfin là
celui-là il est encore c'est vraiment
obvious enfin je sais pas tu peux pas
ouais mais après si tu utilises pas par
exemple parce que il jouait sur
cheeseccom au début
ce qui prouve que leur anti cheating il
progresse
qui avait une grosse progression sur
chaise cam de l'antiquité ok pour moi ça
prouve aussi il vire aussi vite mais
après ouais ils sont partis sur ouais
mais comment
au pire joue sur une petite zone de jeu
ouais mais c'est pareil je pense ah ils
auraient pu se faire choper aussi mais
là sur lichesses c'est vraiment tu
donnes par exemple moi j'utilise pas
comment je peux savoir tu vois qu'on
peut trouver toutes les il se joue
tellement de parties comment tu peux
imaginer en fait que tu peux rechercher
ils ont pas imaginé qu'il faudra changer
comme ça comme sur chaise bas en fait
oui mais c'est tellement énorme le
nombre de parties mais après tu peux te
dire que toutes les petits il y a
quelqu'un qui peut prendre toutes les
petites sommes de jeu et les rassembler
en fait donc voilà c'est vrai c'était
vraiment facile à faire mais est-ce que
Yann était au courant avant la partie
d'avance c'est possible aussi
je pense que tu sais on se rend pas
compte mais c'est tous ces forums là
ready etc en fait c'est beaucoup plus
puissant une communauté Reddit que que
même si tu as cinq gars qui bossent
non-stop
non mais si par exemple si tu as les
il a quand même une équipe de plusieurs
entraîneurs il y a forcément quelqu'un
qui cherche les parties sur Internet qui
est dédié à ça donc s'il trouve il y
avait déjà H3
ça a pu ouais parce qu'après tu vois la
force quand même donc dame G3 il joue
dame G3 logique
MG3 logique et là je crois que c'est roi
F8 alors attends je vais je vais prendre
mon
prépare en Australian Bundesliga
tu vas le mettre sur les genoux sur les
genoux connectés à toutes les turbines
pakistanaises
ils doivent être dégoûtés que ça élite
ça c'est vrai aussi
c'est pour ça que c'est pas jouer fou
c'est ça on n'a pas envie
ouais
mon très logiquement
ça va être joué donc ça on peut déjà le
mettre
et c'est quelques coups en fait l'idée
d'après ce que je vois rapidement sur
sur l'ordi c'est que les Noirs vont
jouer pour D6 et H5 H4 par exemple W F4
plutôt que fout des trois le fou il va
plutôt en les deux parce que tu gardes
la colonne des pour pour la tour et par
exemple webcam D6
et H5 c'est plus ou moins ce qui va se
passer et ça peut c'est une partie qui
peut aller rapidement vers la nulle avec
les échanges en D6 massif
[Musique]
on va voir exactement on va pas c'est
juste pour expliquer pour montrer une
position pourquoi oui par exemple même
si il y a du Tour des rêves avant que on
gagne le pion des
gens
même cette position là c'est juste pour
mettre une position genre même ça ça
serait une bonne version pour les blancs
finalement mais ça va pas gagner ça même
ça ça devrait pas gagner après tout
c'est lui toi
mais bon
[Musique]
on va faire ça comme ça
qualitatif
ça part tout de suite côté Monsieur
Meuble c'est beau
et fougez 5 alors ça c'est une bonne
question mais je pense ça doit être dame
qui vient se placer en face mais
peut-être fou eux deux et ça ça crée
moins d'échange effectivement ça peut
être une idée et ça enlève un peu le H5
H4
[Musique]
il y a aussi du fouet non enfin je sais
pas c'est décidé là
quoi que maintenant peut-être fou F4 ou
F4
c'est bizarre c'est bizarre c'est
position
c'est bizarre il va fouger 5
intéressantes
ok ça ça peut en tout cas ça évite de se
faire sécher comme on vient de se
moi je voulais grands rocks mais
un grand rock attention
tu peux pas tout prendre bon je le
montre
à cause du mat donc 8 on a dit fouger 5
dame 8 x 2 des 6 tour d'air
ok on a encore le temps alors
tu rajoutes
contrôle la case des 8 avec la tour à 8
maintenant
tu vas devoir jouer F4 donc est-ce que
la dame elle est mieux placée en 8 que
en D8 et tu vois sur foie F4 peut-être
que ça peut être l'idée de tout à
l'heure
de donner le pion des 6 mais
après le truc c'est que si dans toutes
les variantes que tu dois le donner ça
devient assez facile à préparer en plus
il y a la pression sur eux
et la tour qui va sortir par H6 donc on
fait un rock un peu et puis tu vas vite
doubler sur eux ou sur ouais et les
faiblesses en C3 C4
même si tu veux jouer le gain avec les
Blancs bah tu vas la tenir quand même
un pion mais on sent que ça peut vite
partir sur des finales également et
c'est pratique d'avoir joué à 5 parce
qu'il y a jamais l'idée des maths du
couloir genre admettons ça
on a toujours le roi H7 donc en plus le
H5 il est doublement utile c'est la tour
qui se développe par en restant sur
place elle fait 0
et toi dans cette prépa ça c'est ordi
évidemment à l'oeil humain tu peux
jamais trouver un tel coup
il s'en souvient bien en plus
d'idoler qui s'est fait plaisir
jusqu'ici les livres et le bœuf wagueux
c'est pas whyu plutôt normalement c'est
arrivé en même temps
il est très bien mais t'as pas encore vu
le drapeau de stunt
je sais pas où il est dans la mis
quelque part
mais Vlad Vlad a laissé le stylo ouvert
sur le drapeau ça c'est beau le stabilo
ouvert sur le drapeau qui a permis de
complètement dégueulasse
le drapeau
on n'a pas surveillé vladimin quoi
ce lieu de vous dire au revoir il a
laissé le stylo
ouais c'est ça c'est il est parti nous a
pas dit au revoir il a laissé le stylo
dessus quoi
alors est-ce que on revient juste avant
roi et fuite comme ça on va bien
expliquer la position ouais
donc tape G7
donc on veut pas se déroquer par tour G8
c'est mieux alors on peut pas ok alors
le plus simple on peut pas ok à cause de
fois H6 tables G7 et sur G6 on prend la
qualité
et donc ça on peut pas G6 on veut pas
non plus parce que là alors on a trois
possibilités de défendre l'option soit
G6 soit au G8 soit roi fit voir fou et
fuite mais bon là c'est trop de pas de
fuite mais G6
[Rires]
aussi logique mais ici
a priori parce que sur X6 il peut y
avoir fouet fuite donc ça reste quelque
chose d'intéressant quand même et fouger
5 x 7
tu as réussi à le suivre par contre on
peut peut-être te faire
des 6 on rentre ça affaiblit j'ai 6 ça
affaiblit il peut y avoir
des six fouger c'est un qui est
intéressant
il y a du H4 qui peut aussi être
intéressant mais il faut des trois c'est
pas mal donc ça en fait j'ai 6 ça faibli
trop les cases noires
et bon et le mieux c'est roi est fuite
parce qu'en fait il se développe par la
tour qui va se développer par H5 le roi
qui se retire de la colonne E pour les
D6 des 35
[Musique]
et c'est quelque chose de vraiment
nouveau c'est arrivé jamais avant parce
qu'en jouant fout ces 5 dames G3 on a
vraiment trop peur en fait donc c'est
ordi ordinateur
une fois que tu as vu tu as vu
ici pour moi en fait c'est pas trois
résultats ici c'est quasiment que un
résultat en fait je pense qu'ils vont
faire nul
la Ding liren il va
pour tes allergies en fait
hier j'ai pas eu de chance
on sait jamais quoi il y a peut-être
c'est pas un ce qui peut y avoir un
petit coup de
en fait ici donc Ding il va réfléchir
longtemps
et c'est logique parce que si il a pas
fou c'est incroyable fuite c'est
peut-être il se dit ça laisse peut-être
une opportunité donc il va essayer de
chercher mais il y a pas de solution et
donc qui réfléchissent une demi-heure
une heure en fait ça absolument la même
chose tu vas choisir fou et deux fous
des trois fois F4 et au final tu choisis
bien tes parties quoi
[Rires]
désolé j'étais coupé mais oui tu allais
dire qu'il choisisse là l'autre nous on
sait que ça change rien en fait
les blancs ils peuvent pas éviter les
échanges j'en ai dit ils veulent éviter
les échanges non ils peuvent pas éviter
de décises en fait des six tu peux juste
pas l'éviter
la ligne en fait
c'est peut-être il vient juste de fermer
turbines qui bossent un peu donc on va
voir après
à savoir que tout le monde n'aime pas
jouer comme ça
tu vois un joueur comme Carlsen il
n'aime pas jouer comme ça c'est pas un
joueur de Petrov tu vois Yann il choisit
Petrov il choisit des lignes où tu vas
quand même
connaître pour faire nul
non ou d'autres enfin
par exemple toi là tu es avec les Noirs
tu es heureux non alors je suis heureux
du monde mais en tournoi non ce que tu
peux pas gagner tu vois tu peux pas
gagner c'est un style un peu
d'époque ah oui oui oui
surtout quand tu le fais en nouveauté
bah oui ça c'est sûr quand tu le fais
pas en nouveauté c'est mais quand tu le
fais en nouveauté là tu es tout sourire
non
je vais rappeler que à mon avis si c'est
parce que jingle il a choisi de jouer au
4 là il y a deux jours
sinon il doit avoir évidemment enfin on
peut pas louper un tel truc si on
travaille longtemps une position par ami
serait bien avec les Noirs il serait
tout sourire non et c'est vrai
il doit pas être bien
mais je ne pense pas comme il était en
Autriche mais il progresse pas mal
apparemment souvent quand même il met
des pouces
mondial on va on va voir flou hein le
jour il va passer devant Maxime moello
on va pas être bien parce que ce jour va
finir par rire il est jeune encore
parano il a 23 ans
de par là ce jour-là ça va suer de notre
côté et t'imagines si parram dépasse à
l'IRESA
on aura vraiment pas le bon iranien mais
non là on va pas être bien
oh là ça va suer il va être tout sourire
en plus
ça arrive on va pas être bien
fashion industrie et oui bon
parram industrie
mais là il va rejoindre ça fait
longtemps ça va faire plaisir ça quand
est-ce que commence le ça commence très
très bientôt c'est le 6 mai je suis
assez impatient puis avoir Ali resa et
Maxime donc ça va être cool
même Maxime moi je le vois jouer tous
les week-ends
ça fait depuis septembre on a hâte
il y a beaucoup alors hier attention à
l'IRESA il commence à se chauffer
puisqu'il a fait un stream avec Nemo en
retard
c'est vrai
c'est réel je passe comme ça sur twitch
et je vois la tête dans les raisins sur
le live de Nemo j'étais obligé de
d'ouvrir et j'étais pas bien
je sais pas elle a inventé un jeu je
sais pas ce qu'elle a fait
ça a pas eu je sais pas lire ça il avait
pas l'air très impressionné quoi
[Musique]
les mots ouais
là celui qui est pas bien c'est
qu'il va faire nul rapide
bah c'est dimanche
il est pas bien du tout là il sait
là il sait
si tu veux revenir avant je peux te
montrer quelle ligne en fait il voulait
il voulait jouer
en ce moment
D3 c'est ça
[Musique]
doit être détroit des 6
à 3
ou quelques parts
C3 mais bon plutôt fou à 5 B4 fou B6
voilà c'est des lignes comme ça qui
voulaient jouer cavalier A4 ici je crois
que c'est ça la ligne
tu vois un peu dans le style de la part
de l'anglaise où il avait dominé
voilà c'est ça qui voulait et là il
s'attendait pas à ça
et je pense que les Noirs ont eu des
problèmes dans la partie après fou C5
alors il y a pas d'autres coups faut
sortir le fou je me rappelle quand
j'étais jeune pour pour rigoler un petit
peu on peut revenir
à la place de fou c'est 5
je jouais pas mal des destins indiennes
[Musique]
j'ai pas trop regardé cette ligne là je
peux pas vous dire exactement mais il y
a eu forcément des problèmes pour que
les gens jouent fou B4 et là on a
l'impression que que il peut alors je
vais vous dire je vais vous donner les
Vals
on passe sur c'est quand même du Zéro 18
mais bon en profondeur 62
ouais mais bon après si tu connais pas
tu connais pas
mais bon profondeur 62 ça veut peut-être
dire qu'il rentre dans une finale un peu
mieux sans plus non
Line qui a pas l'air très agréable pour
les Noirs quand même donc enfin c'est
peut-être qu'il ferme la variante mais
en étant bien
préparé quoi donc à souvenir
après peut-être qu'il s'attendait à un
tel de
ça veut dire que
ça veut dire que ça veut dire que ça va
rentrer dans la finale avec
[Musique]
des six ou F4 H5 tours D1
il va donner le pion des 6 et faire nul
et surtout ces cinq oui cavaliers Pro 5
est forcé enfin c'est l'idée des blancs
parce que quand même c'est pas banal de
jouer au 4 ici c'est pour ça qu'à
l'époque c'était pas du tout
mais tu peux le combler quoi bah en fait
l'idée oui soit on arrive à jouer des
cases soit on y arrive pas mais après
fou c'est ça qu'on est absolument obligé
de prendre si on prend pas comme dans la
ligne tout à l'heure où on a vu avec
après foubecca on prend l'espace à 4,3
B4 cavaliers A4 ici par exemple si on
joue un coup comme détroit
des 6 a ici il y a même que j'ai 4
commencez parfois de D6 D3 ici j'ai pas
envie de donner le fou avec fougère mais
juste petit rock et sur A3 on va jouer à
5 et on va garder le fou sur
on a toutes les cases donc on voit
visuellement c'est déjà mieux pour les
noirs
nous l'avait dit c'est pas un bluffeur
quand il est quand il connaît
normalement
c'est devenu tellement forcé parce qu'à
l'époque on réfléchissait quand même
réfléchissez quand même beaucoup même
quand on connaissait
disons à l'époque je disais à 15 20 ans
parce que les coûts même il y a 10 ans
d'ailleurs parce que des fois tu peux
t'imprégner un peu de la position un peu
voir les plans
ici il y a juste pas de plan c'est
quelqu'un donc faut jouer puis tu remets
la pression à la pendule tu mets la fin
puis des fois on pouvait améliorer là ok
c'est complètement pas améliorable donc
il l'a
c'est beau H5 comme coup ici en plus il
est hyper logique aujourd'hui en tout
cas avec tout ce qu'on sait c'est hyper
logique tu veux du HK tu veux ramener la
tour
facile
et de perdre le pion des 6 ça va
permettre de développer les pièces
noires de l'aile dame donc on a pas
besoin de sortir
ouais on s'occupe de l'aile roi à la H5
H4
et on demande si c'est 100% nul je sais
jamais 100% mais là c'est au dessus de
90% pour moi c'est nul avant 13h
ces femmes qui va pas être bien
au contraire au contraire
si c'est si c'est ce scénario
j'appellerai la partie sur Youtube une
vraie partie de championnat du monde
ça peut arriver
la profondeur de la préparation digne
sur les parties d'avant
parce que il trouvait vraiment des idées
avec le temps qu'ils ont pris d'ailleurs
il jouait des parties d'entraînement en
février ça fait ça fait
quelques mois qui sont sur les idées et
et là on voit que ouais en trois jours
on se fait fermer dans un championnat du
monde
c'est dur de décider en trois jours de
trouver une idée
parce que toutes les ouvertures qu'il a
joué c'est fait avec beaucoup de
comme il a dit le Londres qu'il a joué
au hasard
merci monsieur
[Rires]
mais tu sais je dois te dire que ça fait
progresser un devoir c'est parti de
match de championnat du monde moi je le
sens quoi
on voit beaucoup l'idée et quand tu
joues ça donne des idées en fait
d'analyser à fond c'est parti non mais
ça montre aussi qu'il y a beaucoup
d'erreurs on est plus sur les tournois
on est plus sur les tournois rapides où
il y a pas trop d'erreurs là on est
vraiment sur est-ce qu'il y a vraiment
des spécialistes de matchs de
championnats du monde il y a pas assez
de match pour se spécialiser qui mais
ils sont il y a beaucoup d'erreurs mais
beaucoup de aussi parce qu'il pose aussi
il se pose beaucoup de problèmes
ce serait magnifique que dans les
parties d'entraînement dit qu'il lui a
allumé l'ordi quoi c'est leur dire
[Rires]
je suis plus fort que toi
il a joué
il y a pas de 7 mais après faut jouer à
5 c'est tellement plus logique de jouer
à 5 maintenant
ce qui réfléchit où il est pas et il est
pas assis
que c'est pas dangereux
non mais je pense qu'il pensait que
qu'il allait réfléchir après mais après
il faut F4 c'est tellement forcé
on se demande bien ce qu'il est parti
faire depuis 5 minutes
pour pas revenir comme ça
il n'est pas déjà eu cette position avec
les blancs dans un title
possible
et en fait c'est peut-être un
spécialiste qui lui a joué ça et après
ils ont regardé quoi spécialisé
beaucoup plus fort le title regarde j'ai
fait les fraises
en 2020 oui bon
en fait ouais bon je pense qu'il se
souvient pas de la partie
ouais mais bon on peut quand même dire
que ça joue les mêmes coups en title
qu'en finale de championnats du monde
Cardoso qui lui a joué 24 14
[Musique]
remarque 2020 c'était l'année où ouais
ça a commencé à jouer très fort
s'il analysait la partie juste après ok
peut-être oui une idée chance en fait il
a c'est juste le taie
ça peut changer le titre prépare title
Tuesday peut être un joli titre
et ça joue bien cet high toll
et j'ai une bonne nouvelle là on est
arrivé au bout des places pour
pour la prochaine Ligue le 12 mai il
reste plus que 31 places je crois c'est
beau
ça va être sympa ça
j'espère qu'on les bats les Indiens
on les défonce
à mon doigt
je pense que c'est Katia qui va faire la
différence
elle fait toujours la différence tiens
mille fois personne ne monte il y a que
moi qui monte sur Paris mais peut-être
l'année prochaine moi
j'ai des obligations du coup ok je peux
je joue mais j'ai peur je peux pas
monter sur Paris on a tous des
obligations on nous parle du majeur CS
Go il y a quelqu'un il y a quelqu'un qui
va monter à Paris pour ça
et qui va pas bien certain
si vous trouvez du parano bilan à Paris
c'est la semaine du majeur
j'ai quasiment envie de monter à Paris
juste pour pour
les gens montent à Paris pour aller voir
la finale du 16 Go et d'autres montent à
Paris pour voir par hame qui va avoir la
finale du 16 Go ouais tu prends mes
places au final
mais l'année prochaine j'espère qu'on
fera jouer toute l'équipe depuis Paris
bah ça serait bien que toutes les
équipes jouent en présentiel
mais je pense que ça serait fantastique
je peux payer pour ça en fait
ça aurait été complexe je pense mais
ouais mais avec
quand ta reine en fait tout devient
possible parce qu'il a de l'argent
mais il en a
il vit à deux heures de terrain
et malheureusement Maxime pourra pas
jouer parce qu'il joue donc je remplace
Maxime oui mais ce qu'on perd vraiment
d'après Sacha oui
et pas bien Sacha
mais bon bah quand je lui ai dit un
moment donné ouais Maxime bon il est
moyen motivé mais maybeck Maxime
stronger
il a fermé la discussion instantanément
en fait on verra on verra on s'en rend
pas trop compte mais en vrai c'est Sacha
qui fait l'équipe en fait parce que
Katia elle voulait plus jouer comme je
t'ai dit j'ai déjeune avec elle m'a dit
ok Sacha il a dit oui non il YouPlay bon
en fait oui c'est ça qui fait toute
l'équipe
là je suis pas passé sur la partie la
plus passionnante
est-ce qu'il envoie le hcincotte tempo
ou est-ce qu'il prend un peu son temps
il connaît
Sacha était d'accord pour bakipier ouais
ouais ça va
mais quand il a vu les deux premières
parties de Maël c'était moi je t'avais
dit mais écrit sur WhatsApp yangsters
[Rires]
avec un tel au quatrième ok on peut
arrêter la compétition déjà c'est beau
mais après elle
un stream avec Sacha Baki et Vlad
pourrait mettre fin au streaming
français et le problème c'est que Sacha
parle pas français malheureusement
parler français il nous aurait déjà
fermé depuis longtemps
et je crois que c'est pratique
pour eux c'est vrai ouais c'est une
sorte
mais ce serait beau d'avoir un live avec
parram aussi
Twitter quand même moi j'espère avoir la
dédicace après le Top 12 là j'attends
attends t'imagines le gagner aux échecs
dédicacé par parram
c'est une œuvre c'est l'autre coup mais
aussi
quoi
il va devoir jouer à H5 ça c'est sûr
et Sacha c'est qui ouais c'est Alexander
grishuk
tour
c'est peut-être une bonne nouvelle pour
le suspense de la partie
c'est pas rappelé
oubliez
parce que maintenant c'est la même avec
un temps de moins tourner un H5
ok tu peux faire rock H4 dame D3
maintenant et surpuis on prend tu vas
voir dame D8 alors que si en commençant
par H5 bah en plus c'est un peu c'est un
peu
H5 c'est un coup forcé le H5
donc et là du coup ça faisait quoi sur
Dame des trois tu peux faire G5
et tu prends l'espace quoi ou E3 tu
prends tu fais H3 tu fais damocet au
final tu vas rentrer dans cette finale
soit H3 là tu vois puis on prend des 6
enfin le pion mais on a plus ou moins
mais bizarre dame c'est toi donc il se
souvient pas bah pas facile de souvenirs
des détails et après dame cette tour
d'air là ça va commencer à être un petit
peu chaud ouais parce que comme tu dis
sur H5 maintenant il y a petit rock H4
Dame des trois
et
bon il y a pas de G5 parce qu'il y a
alors
ouais mais tu as perdu un temps sur la
finale quand même ouais peut-être que ça
va fois si c'est 4 ouais ça fait une
c'est moins clair
je pense que ça va quand même par
exemple ouais disons ouais peut-être par
Royal peut-être GF
et peut-être torser vite à ton profil
ça devrait ok complexe le pion h il peut
être tu peux peut-être faire G4 ouf de
roi G3
mais mon tour assez vite il y aura assez
vite pour ces 5 tu auras 5 c'est ça
devient un combat quand même on est sur
un combat
elles sont bien placées tout de suite tu
as un bon placement de pièces parce que
tour C5 je peux te faire Rouger 3 tu
auras 5 Tourdes non
mais bon tu as encore enfin tu auras
trois tu as quand même de l'activité
mais le pire
quand même
mais bon tu vas perdre
de plus mais
en bonne santé
parce que tu vois moi franchement je
vois cette position de loin j'ai pas
envie avec les Noirs toi ça te fait pas
peur ça mais toi après tu défends
tellement bien
tu as peur de rien mais non mais en fait
je comprends pas pourquoi c'est quoi son
idée parce que regardons je vais juste
poser l'ordi parce que là je vois que
les lignes elles sont complexes elles
sont bien comprendre qu'est-ce qui veut
après tourner en fait
il veut des prendre 5 peut-être
vous prend
F6 et si je vais bouffer C7 pardon j'ai
pas
peut-être qu'il veut défendre comme ça
mais ça fait un petit peu j'aime pas
tourner
déjà en train de regarder
six peut-être direct du coup
faut prendre à me prendre mais bon
faut être solide quoi là il a fait
tourner
ouais attention quand même Yann ouais
parce que s'il a pas le coup H5 avant ça
veut dire qu'ici
enfin tu vois il a réfléchi quand même
c'est qu'il a pas bien il a pas trouvé
l'idée H5 donc en fait il se souvient
plus de sa partie contre Cardoso je me
souviens pas de mais enfin je me
souviens de certains title des parties
vraiment marquantes mais des premières
parties jamais mon cardozone car deux
autres
parce que c'est pas le title qui lui
fait perdre le titre tout simplement
et tu vois toi on voit retour 2007 ok tu
joues tous les mardis quoi
[Rires]
on voit la différence tous les mardis tu
es là
oui d'ailleurs il va falloir remonter le
niveau là un petit peu
mais oui ce mardi ouais je serai pas
encore au top mardi d'après parce qu'on
va arriver vers la prothèse League donc
tourner un bon coup et ouais donc j'ai
pas pourquoi pas jouer à 5 avant ça veut
dire qu'il va peut-être pas le jouer ça
veut dire qu'il va planter en fait sur
cette position après tourner c'est à
dire qu'il est pas bien non
parce qu'à part
H5 ou déprime 5 comment on peut jouer
tu as pas d'autres couleurs
peut-être même du Tour des cinq mais là
tu reprends des 6 tours 8
alors on va ouais il faut prendre des
six il faut prendre des 6 on va le
montrer quand même
voilà donc on donne pas il y a le
courage mais étant 8 tours 8 tour des
deux et maintenant H5 peut-être et t'as
pas foudé 3 j'ai dames prends bon petit
mais peut-être H5 c'est peut-être ça
bien joué oui
et pourquoi pas avant h54 alors ouais on
va essayer de comprendre un peu tout
pourquoi pas H5 H4 d'ailleurs pourquoi
pas
c'est
trop en fait ça me fait penser à son
trick de la première partie le cavalier
de 5 et maintenant il a ça
H4 Dame des trois je t'ai coupé avec le
trick
du tas de dire la première partie
il y avait un thème tactique incroyable
oui mais oui trop dur trop dur mais là
en fait il
devait se souvenir mais peut-être qu'il
s'est souvenu à l'inverse il y a
peut-être pas vu le petit rock ici
si la joie H5 mais ça me fait pour moi
ça fait pas beaucoup de sens de
commencer quand même par dame cette si
tu veux jouer H5 en fait ouais mais
après c'est tellement sur du détail
[Musique]
pas forcément même H4 là honnêtement il
peut le faire parce que des fous prends
et fougères mais ce qui peut pas faire
fou G4 au lieu de tout de suite
parce que là d'un projet 4 il y a pas
d'écran et 5 tours
G4
et avec idée sur franc à petit
ok c'est pas si ouais en fait c'est dur
à trouver
par exemple H3
G3 normalement regardons d'abord j'ai
trois
mais ouais là il est peut-être pas
obligé de
ouais comment on a pu les G5
où est-ce qu'il a pas gs5 regardons
tout à l'heure mais pas tout à fait la
même ouais mais ça va retomber dans la
même puisqu'on avait quand même fait je
crois par obligation non mais là on voit
que c'est un peu mieux
OK
donc c'est pas dit que ça ouais c'est
pas dit que ça ait la nul hein tu es sur
90% nul en fait on est ouais
c'est pas si sûr
avec les Noirs mais ouais en fait c'est
le problème c'est l'avantage maintenant
c'est qu'on peut jouer des tels coupe
fou c'est cinq croix fuite mais comme je
disais au tout début de fin quand ils
l'ont joué c'est que nous quand jouer
cette position à l'époque c'est des
cours on sait même pas parce que
regardez ça l'air hyper dangereux
et c'est dur la défense elle est dure
aux échecs on l'a vu sur toutes les
parties il y a trop il y a trop
d'erreurs
on peut pas enfin il y a beaucoup
d'erreurs parce que c'est hyper dur
alors que dans le cas de Ding regardez
il avait beaucoup de coups possible il
avait 4-5 coups possibles
ah il a même pas choisi le meilleur
objectivement mais ça suffit à mettre la
pression mais j'aime pas trop dame 7 il
a joué trop vite en fait il se souvient
pas exactement il devait pas jouer dame
si vite
j'aime pas trop son la façon dont après
il s'est peut-être souvenu dans le
mauvais ordre
ce qu'ils ont tellement on a tellement
d'informations à intégrer
alors il y a pas d'adversaire en face
c'était pas là la première journée Rio
zen
mais en fait quand tu joues ton cou en
général ouais on reste pas trop sur
l'échiquier surtout que là il y a quand
même pas mal de possibilités on doit
garder l'énergie pour tu peux pas rester
4 heures concentrées à fond à fond
[Musique]
quant à moins de temps là ils ont encore
beaucoup de temps Yann il a une heure 45
encore la pendule donc
[Musique]
il peut se permettre d'être un peu
relâché d'attendre le coup parce que pas
de perte d'énergie sur H4 sur petit rock
il y a trop de coupe aussi pour les
blancs et vaut mieux attendre que le
problème arrive pour le régler
Orico 444 non je me prépare bah en
regardant les streams de Kevin et en
jouant les titles
F5 parce qu'en dit la scandinave tu es
prêt comme jamais si quelqu'un t'envoie
une scandinave je pense que tu vas
rigoler non
trop facile
peut-être jouer la scandinave des 8
mais c'est la Dame des six non qui est
quand même mieux réputée la dame D8
c'est Carlsen qui avait joué ça à Carole
aux Olympia
comme quoi mais c'est solide quand même
c'est typiquement le joueur qui aime pas
trop jouer de la façon les lignes de
Yann jouent aujourd'hui il préfère jouer
un truc même s'il a un tout petit peu
moins bien
où il va jouer des coups enfin ça dépend
à quel moment mais pour jouer dans ce
style là avec les Noirs faut réviser 3-4
heures par jour c'est un peu dur surtout
quand tu joues des théoriciens comme
Ding ou Kawana
je pense qu'il a joué dame 7 parce que
il se souvient de H4 fougères mais qu'il
l'a fait dans le mauvais sens et qu'il
l'a joué un peu vite dans le 7
candidat j'aime bien la jouer en belette
il y a une belle partie de Bobby Fisher
d'ailleurs dans la scandinave D8 qui est
dans son livre mais 60 meilleurs parties
pourquoi je m'en souviens pas je pense
c'est qu'on sera dit ça dans un truc
comme ça
je me souviens pas de tôt
on va avoir une partie aujourd'hui j'ai
pas contre
il y en a deux en fait de ce scandinave
D8
non c'est pas Robin
c'est parti contre les meilleurs joueurs
du monde mais tu sais pourquoi je le
connais incroyable il était l'éditeur en
chef de 64
regardez
moi je l'ai vu en 2006 c'était pas cher
oui
mais qui était directeur
de Vlad ou de Mortas mais au chat
parce qu'en fait j'ai travaillé sur un
projet avec Hero Charles erasbach en
même temps
c'est la même c'est la même génération
mais alors je connais pas fantastique
d'ailleurs parce que Rochal pardon la
fois où j'ai j'ai gagné le championnat
de Moscou moins de 2004
et
du coup je sais plus comment il a tourné
en russe mais
en grosso modo je lui dis ok bah je joue
un peu aux échecs je dis ouais j'ai
gagné le tournoi là à Moscou
et il m'a sorti en rigolant
mincedes vaticien
oui bon je gagne pas mais toi je me
prenais pas trop sérieux mais en plus je
parlais pas bien russe à l'époque et il
m'a sorti ça
en rigolant encore en sautant de ma
gueule en fait
c'était pas mal déjà alors on nous a
demandé si elle est contrôles
anti-topage oui ils ont eu un contrôle
antidopage hier ou avant-hier
après c'est pas le plus gros problème
des échecs bien sûr c'est un problème
dans tous les c'est un problème quand
même le dopage
mais
pas hôtel point que la triche
électronique enfin
la triche d'information on va dire
comment parler de 64 c'est une revue que
tu lisais toi ou pas 64 c'est un peu
ouais ouais bah moi je le connaissais
enfin je le connaissais mes entraîneurs
donc oui on demande si je parlais un peu
russe oui je parle un peu je comprends
un petit peu je parle un petit peu
c'était quand même au tout début avec
avec Dorfman pendant longtemps mais là
où j'ai vraiment bien progressé c'est
avec Nikitine ce qui parlait
il parlait très mal anglais
en français mais on avait quelques
quelques bases
et avec Nikitine j'ai commencé à être
obligé de parler
à stunt qui est pas bien
journal que j'aimerais bien recevoir 64
je sais pas si c'est possible de le
recevoir ici je le lisais en fait quand
j'habite en Russie moi je l'ai reçu un
moment après c'est un bon journal et
puis j'aime bien les
études les colonnes de cousines
j'aime bien globalement
je le connais un peu IRL il est hyper
marrant il travaillait avec Moro
c'est ça ouais tu as raison
Moreau qui travaille avec une époque
aussi je crois qu'ils ont plus trop en
contact
possible
alors on nous donne toutes
les idées là pour pour que je gagne la
Coupe du Monde
toutes les idées de dopage
s'il y a 7 7 et ce qui armage s'il y a 7
7 il y aura des départages en rapide et
en blitz mais on n'y est pas encore
et là n'est pas il est pas revenu sur
l'échiquier mais il doit pas être très
bien en fait il comprend que
[Musique]
malheureusement ni kitté est décédé
assez récemment
deux ans
il avait quel âge tu sais
j'ai fait quelques stages là-bas dans
les datchas
c'est un entraîneur de Gary moi j'ai
beaucoup de d'entraîneurs de
second ans entraîneur de Gary qui
évidemment qui était est-ce que tu as eu
la clé USB à 5000 balles donc là tu as
parlé est-ce que tu es en contact avec
cette clé USB je travaille un peu avec
un
oui
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça me fait marrer en fait
on me demande si c'est pas trop dur
d'être cependant non en fait pour l'ego
si c'est pas trop dur d'être seconde
pour Richard je sais pas en fait je
pense qu'il le fait parce que ça l'aide
et qu'il est très bien avec les je pense
qu'ils ont travaillé avec les joueurs
chinois depuis un certain temps
mais pour moi une fois que tu as décidé
que ton meilleur niveau est passé c'est
juste hyper intéressant en fait c'est ce
que d'essayer de trouver c'est ce qu'on
adore faire par exemple un joueur comme
Vlad au moins tu trouves encore les
idées c'est même yoshifman il continue à
le faire maintenant ça fait il adore
c'est des choses qu'on adore faire de
trouver un peu la vérité en fait de
trouver des
après on pourrait comparer ça à un
entraîneur de foot Fajr tu as été joueur
de haut niveau et puis la plupart enfin
tous les joueurs mais genre après tu
deviens entraîneur d'un club c'est
logique enfin tu continues pas à jouer à
45 ans enfin bah tu peux oui tu peux
plus ouais
tu es quand même content d'être encore
au contact du top top niveau ah bah
ouais moi j'adore
mais après ça des petites pauses ça fait
du bien aussi
après c'est sûr que seconde
on peut on peut le dire
on va sentir ensemble je crois qu'on
peut
mais ouais donc c'est c'est peut-être
que bientôt tu auras un nouveau poulain
on sait pas quoi et peut-être même tu en
as déjà mais tu nous le dis pas quoi ce
serait aussi possible
j'ai déjà
profité pour finir God of War
j'ai déjà fini mon bouquin ah oui c'est
vrai du coup bah je sais pas dans un
mois
c'est pas Noël 2023
non je pense je vais si je le fais pas
là il sera si je le finis pas en mai en
fait je le finirai jamais ok je vais le
finir là mais donc il va sortir en
septembre non
tu sors en septembre à la rentrée quoi
mais après faut quand même qui passe à
l'imprimeur le machin et tout c'est long
en fait
il y a encore un mois une fois une fois
que tu l'as terminé il y a encore un
mois bah tiens
tu as pas l'air bien
important ah oui mais d'ailleurs en
parlant de chez sarama c'est l'heure de
la pause c'est en fait c'est pas une
nappe c'est un jeu non
je mets la pub comme ça tu vas pouvoir
le revoir donc on fait une petite pause
bah c'est la pause chez sarama et on
revient et d'ici une dizaine de minutes
pour pour la suite de la partie à tout
de suite les amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les amis on a la position qu'on pensait
avoir
après H4 Dame des trois et donc ça va
être ça va être tendu
qui va revenir dans une dans une petite
minute c'était la pause la pause café
importante café Ted
mais ouais le Dame des trois le Dame des
trois qui est gênant on peut plus
prendre en E5 et on va peut-être rentrer
dans la fameuse finale
ouais donc position qui va qui va être
intéressante on va voir où ça nous mène
un petit récapitulatif ouais ben écoute
tu as dit facile à une Anglaise le 4 fou
c'est 5 un coup plus très à la mode mais
avec avec une idée qui a eu Yann c'était
ici de jouer le fou c'est 5 donc qui est
rarissime comme coup puisque après dame
G3 on peut pas faire rock à cause de
fois 6 donc ça paraît mauvais mais avec
roi et F8 food 2 sur un jeu précis à
base de H5 H4 et D6 on pouvait on
pouvait égaliser alors H5 ici je crois
de mémoire qui était le coup mais Yann
qui a inversé et maintenant sur Rock H4
il y a dame D3 et il y avait d'autres
variantes où on pouvait donner le pion
simplement ici on perd un tempo en ayant
joué dame 7 on aurait pu donner le pion
dans de manière équivalente mais sans
avoir joué dameset donc en échangeant
directement avec dames prends des 6 et à
cause de ça Jean-Michel à peu près avec
les noirs qui bah c'est pas rappelé de
sa prépa et qui va être un petit peu
moins bien c'est Yann à peu près en fait
tu te rappelles cette rêve Jean-Michel à
peu près prenez les chansons à peu près
mais c'est bien ça mais difficile d'être
précis précis dans ces parties il est
fort dingue il a trouvé tous les coups
assez vite pendant la pause et la dame
des trois aussi vite
il a joué il a joué rapidement il envoie
donc ça veut dire qu'il avait les idées
il avait le GSM
qu'on a montré tout à l'heure on peut
peut-être les remonter
il va y avoir la pause parce que là il
va jouer il va prendre rapidement mais
ça va rentrer là-dedans on a montré
cette ligne 45 minutes non
F4 ouais Jeff parce que sur G4 sur du F5
donc GF casse un peu la structure
enfin affaiblit la structure là le
problème c'est que le pion h après GF
alors on va regarder GF3 on peut
imaginer le pion H4 en G6 par exemple
sans aucun problème pour les Noirs
facile mais là avec l'option H4 alors il
va se faire taper par la Tourette donc
on croyais ça tient
roi E7 tours DD4 tape le pion H3 obligé
et maintenant G4 et on voit que le pion
il va être en difficulté enfin ça va
être le défaut de la position noire le
même pion en H6 malgré le pion de moins
on ferait nul très facilement grâce à la
mauvaise structure blanche à l'aile dame
on va voir la tour A8 qui va vraiment
gêner les pions par tour C8 tours C5
tour à 5 qui attaque de partout là elle
peut arriver en A3 facilement
c'est la variante qu'on avait regardé
tout à l'heure celle-là avec toi 5 tour
des deux tour à 3 qui est logique je
trouve que c'est la variante la plus
explicative en fait
de ce qui peut se passer je sais pas
s'il y a les correcte mais et là on voit
que bon même si les Noirs ont
décompensation ça va ouais à cause du
pion H3 il y a le fouet il faut prendre
S3 qui peut qui peut tomber on voit
qu'il y a encore du jeu
c'est le mur tasse qui me disait quand
j'avais un pion de plus comme ça ils
étaient pas un pion de plus tu as un
tempo de plus
mais c'est vrai ce qui va falloir un
coup pour le manger quoi ouais mais bon
de l'autre côté on est très bien avec
enfin à cause du pion
faible de l'autre côté donc ouais ben on
va on va à la position va arriver de
toute façon
et là il sait
ça va être une petite pressante
mais de loin on voit toujours est-ce que
il a pas l'air qui est non plus non mais
il est quand même pas
[Musique]
alors attends là alors dit propose
fouille
peut-être pas idiot
[Musique]
parce que pour vous
même
[Musique]
j'hésiterais quand même moi ça me donne
envie
alors c'est moi et attention il faut
prendre aussi
à cette attention à cette peut-être
[Musique]
un truc de jeu pour du rapide ou du
Blitz
non le roi il est assez solide même si
on fait du roi G8 on est pas si mal en
fait c'est pas il va il va jouer la
finale après la finale tu as un avantage
clair net précisé au risque c'est sûr
parce que le roi est faible mais le foot
casse blanche 2 il t'incite pas
l'attaque quand même
fou et le remettre en D4 oui là ce
serait bien
mais donc c'est pas si automatique vous
prend des 6 c'est le meilleur coup mais
tu peux te permettre de prendre trois
quatre minutes quand même
ouais mais le fou c'est ça qui est trop
fort même un fou c'est un non
je vois pas trop de coup
mais je pense que notre variante elle
est hyper logique
même si la et si tu commences par roi E7
tour de cadre ça change rien façon tu
vas devoir faire fou aussi safeca ouais
ça retombe toujours dans cette position
après si tu veux je peux regarder avec
un gros ordi mais c'est curiosité
[Musique]
d'avoir les valves d'un gros ordi ici
c'est intéressant peut-être si on peut
peut-être réfléchir un tout petit peu
avant fou et 6
ouais ici
juste pour voir d'un côté plus humain
comment faire
si on commence par H3 G3 après quand les
blancs vont jouer F4 ça va donner
l'option en plus de jouer GF aussi
le temps la ça peut être intéressant ça
se regarde non mais
pour humain c'est commencer par cette je
sais pas j'aime bien aussi les tours
décape maintenant l'ordi propose si tu
commences comme ça
ah ouais c'est intéressant sur gicleur
je pense qu'il veut partir de l'autre
côté ah il veut tout
aussi
et là est-ce que la F4 c'est trop
sauf s'il y a du Fou F3 mais attends
est-ce que je
attends je vais t'entendre un truc une
maison
tu es sûr ok je te fais confiance
t'es pas venu sans munitions je suis pas
venu sans munition
S
[Musique]
ça fait ça rajoute des variantes
c'est vrai qu'il va calculer un petit
peu les taux mais il faut aussi c'est
juste obligé en fait
est-ce que tu peux faire un truc comme
F4 si on prend fou F3 aussi
je regarde pour les blancs vraiment
facile quoi tu veux enfin il a fait tout
prendre des 6 ouais mais ça veut dire
que tu as beaucoup de possibilités
il a pas l'air très inquiet non plus bon
je serais inquiet quand même à sa place
de toute façon il va prendre en décises
deux fois
son G5 était forcé
qu'il a fait les coûts forcés
mais là il a peut-être en train de se
dire où est-ce que ça s'est mal passé
parce que c'est ma prépa comment c'est
possible en fait d'être en souffrance et
que je sois pas au courant que ça soit
la souffrance
ce qu'il le voit bien qu'il en soit il
fait nul le soir
j'aimerais pas la jouer avec les Noirs
contre MDL celle-là
tu sues quand même là dessus
cariakin ça peut faire une belle game là
maximum ah d'ailleurs tu vois bah ces
lignes finalement j'avais vraiment pas
vu mais tu as dit il faut aussi sur des
quatre ah maintenant F4 ouais il avait
tombé mais j'attendais peut-être avec la
grosse turbine à cette position parce
que c'est intéressant
logique c'est compliqué les amis mais
c'est une belle partie c'est un dans un
registre complètement différent ça on
l'a pas encore vu dans ce championnat du
monde la petite finale l'avantage
ouais on l'a vu dans cette voie à quel
point c'est difficile de jeu de la
défense il est passé à tellement peu de
perles en fait c'est un tout petit enfin
oui non mais on l'a vu mais pour moi
c'est un peu différent dans le sens où
en fait là c'est le début du combat là
finalement petit avantage tu vois dans
quel sens je veux dire mais oui on l'a
vu dans salle d'avant il est pas passé
loin
d'avoir problème alors attendez un Baki
qui va mettre sa grosse grosse turbine
et on fait que résumé le truc c'est
qu'on l'a fait il y a il y a 5 minutes
Ronflex
5 10 minutes tu es arrivé un tout petit
peu tard pour le résumé mais après tu
retrouves à chaque fois sur YouTube les
parties analysées à posteriori et là en
fait on est en train d'essayer de
comprendre la on va juste remontrer
à quel moment il s'est trompé et
pourquoi il s'est trompé donc il s'est
clairement se tromper je suis passé un
tout petit peu vite
il fallait jouer H5 et on voit qu'il
s'est trompé dans sa prépa parce qu'il a
joué ses coups suivants assez rapidement
même là il réfléchit un moment il doit
pas réfléchir juste au moment précis
après ça ferait pas c'était clairement
ici H5
et sur Rock pour faire comme dans la
partie H4 Dame des trois on va suivre la
partie
H4
H4 dame de 3 et G5
et c'est exactement
ce qu'il a fait rapidement parce que
c'est pas sûr que dans la partie G5 ça
soit le meilleur cours ça ressemble
d'ailleurs pas du tout au meilleur coup
mais en fait il s'en souvient il s'est
mal souvenu je pense juste parce que ça
c'est clairement la ligne qui qui pense
avoir là sur l'échiquier enfin qui va
dans laquelle voulait rentrer du coup là
commencez par Dame
des trois c'est difficile
il a les coups est-ce qu'il va tenter
ton moi j'étais sur le Tour B1 mais
alors là mais leur dire regarde encore
beaucoup plus fort que moi il veut
baisser pour B5
[Musique]
attention tour C6 il y a roi des 7
enferme quasiment la tour
je vais regarder mais tant des cas tu
presses en fait tour des cas tu veux
juste jouer avec ces 5 et avoir un pion
de plus quoi non ça c'est une belle idée
tu peux même jouer F4 maintenant
d'ailleurs
mais après
parce que tout c'est je vais mettre sa
ligne mais en fait quand tu arrives là
tu bouffes ça ok si c'est ça
bon on va peut-être un peu la jouer
quand même
on va peut-être un peu la jouer donc
ouais en fait tourbé 1 et tourbé mais
j'aime bien ce enfin tourbière j'aime
ouais j'adore le tomber pour tomber 5
j'avais pas vu l'idée de tomber sans
quand même et tomber pour tomber 5 c'est
intéressant moi j'aime bien F4 pour
casser tout de suite la structure mais
tomber un tombé 5 pour se débarrasser du
pioncer si ça marche ouais bah là il va
réfléchir donc juste pour bien expliquer
à l'idée comme backy le disait pour bien
que vous voyez en fait on veut provoquer
B6 donc ça c'est logique hein faut
défendre le pion mettre la tour en B5
gagner un tempo de l'autre côté bon
disons recette pour des quatre parce que
c'est la meilleure mine pour l'ordi ton
G8 et maintenant qu'on a provoqué le B6
on va pouvoir jouer du C5 donc on peut
pas tout de suite
parce que il y a peut-être un problème
avec le pion à deux mais quoi qu'il en
soit on peut commencer par A4 de toute
façon et surtout c'est 8 à 5
et là ça commence à être intéressant sur
puis on prend tout reprend on va pouvoir
faire ces 5 mettre le tour à 4 et si un
jour on trouve on troque le pion C5
contre le pion à 7 mais on restera avec
le pion C3 en plus donc là on commence
vraiment à apprécier on a quand même ce
pion de plus même s'il est doublé et
l'activité des pièces
donc ça peut et sans compter qu'on a
toujours l'idée de F4 pour venir
affaiblir le pion H4 de l'autre côté
donc là on commence à multiplier les
problèmes et ça ça paraît vraiment fort
visuellement tomber un tourbé 5 ça
paraît peut-être encore plus fort que F4
et le coût est sympa
en fait ce qui est incroyable
c'est que cette ligne que tu viens de
montrer
donc ça c'est forcément
ça a l'air vraiment de mettre avantage
blanc à 5 tours C5 AB te reprends puis
on prend on prend ici F4 ça paraît
gagnant mais ici il y a GF tour reprend
et H3 et en fait après j'ai trois tour à
8 c'est juste nul
il pourra pas rentrer dedans
il va dévier un endroit tu rentres pas
là-dedans de gaieté de cœur non les
coups sont forcés c'est vraiment forcé
tu peux pas te tromper en fait avec les
Noirs non plus
ça c'est du bol ça c'est du bol que ça
soigne et parce qu'en plus sur G4 au
coup d'avance j'ai 4 chez F5
c'est du bol F5 c'est un gros coup de
bol et j'ai trois tour à 8 ok j'ai pas
compris pourquoi c'est nul mais c'est
nul
[Musique]
mais il a de la chance parce qu'il a
joué vite fou aussi de la même façon
c'est le coup comme il expliquait Vlad
sur
Yann attention il peut craquer à mon
avis encore c'est pas fait
il a commencé par F4 il a joué F4
et donc F4 plus fort à cause de ça
sinon c'était vraiment dur
est-ce qu'il a loupé l'idée est-ce que
il a joué un peu vite
je trouve Ding mais bon mais après F4 tu
mets la pression moi j'aime bien tu vas
faire c'est le premier coup qui m'est
venu à l'esprit de son fort en fait les
deux sont forts
que il voulait pas jouer un truc forcé
de toute façon ça resterait un petit
avantage après F4 il pense que la partie
peut durer plus longtemps
et c'est clair qu'après F4 tu donnes
plus d'options à ton adversaire en plus
je viens de penser tu peux même avoir
l'idée aussi alors
cette tour des 4 5 en une idée dans
lequel on a pas pensé c'est tu peux
aussi jouer pour G3 fois et tout H4
ouais mais ça c'est un peu long je pense
en général tu vas rentrer dans une
finale de tourte à l'autre tour à 8 qui
va arriver en A5 et qui va prendre a
donc c'est plutôt gk3f2 roi G3 en fait
je voulais si tu avais le tour enfin bon
je vais pour expliquer jusqu'au bout
quoi ce à quoi je pensais admettons ça
en fait je me disais que là bon
admettons j'en sais rien quoi je voulais
jouer un en fait que même cette finale
elle était peut-être intéressante
je suis pas sûr mais ta première idée
dire tu aurascade ça marche pas parce
qu'il a trop d'activités de l'autre côté
en tout cas c'est la partie
on avait on avait
c'était la variante principale voilà ça
va être tout F4 il y a pas d'autres
coups
quoi que
attends il peut aussi je crois que ça
marche pas mais il pourrait c'est aussi
calculer H3 bravo ça c'est un joli coup
bravo
il a beaucoup de chance de pas être
perdant bol mais incroyable parce que là
tu as tourgé 5 et surtout à 4 tu as fou
des 5
non mais il a mis
parce que du coup tu rentres dans cette
finale elle est nulle
non mais Baki il a un bol mais
incroyable de
c'est incroyable le bol qu'il a là
incroyable
il a joué H3 déjà
3 marche pas à cause de cette variante
c'est trop
ouais bon c'est trop
qui joue un peu vite quand même parce
qu'il sait pas pourquoi il m'ont dit la
chance par rapport à quoi ben en fait il
pourrait y avoir une variante qui perd
de manière directe et ça tient tout au
coûtait partout et il a pas pu voir tout
ça à l'avance c'est impossible donc il a
du bol que ça tienne partout après dans
les échecs il faut du bol c'est comme
dans tous les sports oui parce que
depuis le coup G5
donc
pas pu analyser et en fait il l'a joué
parce qu'il pensait que c'était son
et tu peux être juste perdant en fait
dans une telle finale ouais ouais ça
pourrait juste être gagnant en force et
ça ne l'est pas mais c'est c'est pas du
tout anticipé quoi et Ding je trouve
qu'il joue un peu vite tous les coups
logiques c'est vraiment les coups de
logique parce qu'on les a regardé tout à
l'heure mais il cherche pas trop les
opportunités supplémentaires c'est en
quelque sorte aussi il a de la chance de
rien rater enfin du coup les deux ont un
peu ont du bol à leur manière ici
il est pas encore sorti d'affaires ah
non il est pas sorti d'affaires mais ça
pourrait être plus à 50 déjà
on a dit que c'était jouable
c'était problématique
c'est le minimum en fait mais il y a pas
mis
maintenant
la tour va arriver en A5 il y a beaucoup
d'activités donc il va lâcher H qui va
prendre un pion de l'autre côté et
probablement tenir même si encore un peu
en difficulté et c'est là que je vois
que ton tour B1 tourbé 5 il était
peut-être plus
bah il était joli tour bien tombé
[Musique]
optimale
bon ben ça mais ça va ça va jouer encore
un long moment ah oui non mais c'est
encore mieux pour le blanc de toute
façon c'est plus mais
est-ce que c'est le match champion le
plus palpitant selon toi depuis une
vingtaine d'années ils sont tous ils
sont tous beaux à leur manière les
voitures du monde bon celui de la
dernière fois il a il s'est arrêté un
peu trop tôt
avec cette septième ronde en fait mais
qui était jusqu'à la septième il était
juste incroyable
et si Yann perd pas contre carlsans
cette OK et il faut se souvenir quand
même de la finale qui a sorti Carlsen
avec tour cavalier de pions là contre la
dame que c'était une partie juste
fantastique le match s'est arrêté un peu
plus tôt donc après celle-là c'était
fini mais jusque là c'était
extraordinaire
depuis longtemps
mais contre karwana c'était hyper
intéressant surtout le début après la
fin bon et contre kariakité c'était
juste tellement proche que
toujours palpitant peut-être que le plus
simple pour Carlsen ça a été contre
kerwana en fait même s'il a eu quelques
problèmes dans les ouvertures il a loupé
la première partie et la dernière partie
il a fait nul dans un avec l'avantage
une position
plus de le plus de problèmes mais
normalement
mais là on est sur
un match stressé 5 bien joué
donc tout à l'heure j'avais évalué un
peu mieux pour les blancs ici bon
0000000
un placard
mais ouais tu vois juste Yann il a pas
de
d'alternative sur tous ces coups qui
joue très vite
les coups forcés depuis G5 tous ces
coups tu peux pas faire un autre c'est
trop c'est trop obligatoire alors c'est
peut-être pas obligatoire pour l'ordi
mais pour les humains
depuis très longtemps en fait bah oui
c'est pour ça qu'on les a trouvés
2004 c'était un match
très intéressant aussi surtout grâce à
Vlad et oui
je lui avais dit de ne pas jouer la 44
est-ce qu'il y a le Fab qui arrive voilà
surtout surtout Michel
bien sûr madame
c'est une belle dame cette Micha tu as
reçu un hérisson aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être ça qu'il faut faire
tourner les hérissons
alors le Fab est-ce que tu as un peu
regardé la partie ou pas du tout le F de
loin de loin de loin voilà vas-y avec
ton œil fabesque qu'est-ce que tu penses
de la finale
l'Oeil du Coach
non je sais pas peut-être un peu essayer
mais probablement
merci au revoir merci messieurs bon
Flins
c'est pas non plus d'être drôle
même si il est pas magnifique il en plus
et oui bon on verra bien
ça peut être un temps de plus le conseil
de Murtas et messieurs et tu as trois
peut-être un moment tu peux aller le
choper tu vois donc tu as des petits
motifs d'espoir quoi bon cela dit après
comment tu fais concrètement ça voilà
bah c'est pas ma partie
c'est beau la même réaction en même
temps
il met les pions sur case blanche
je sais pas trop quel est l'idée
[Musique]
c'est pas si grave mais oui pourquoi
faire en fait
[Musique]
une idée mais
visuellement je sais pas trop
parce que vous en fait vous aviez une
sorte de petit plan pour essayer de
progresser
trois tu auras 5 tour des deux et on se
dit ok si mais la tour on vient en C2 et
on voulait faire fouet F1 faut pour un
autre tu sais on est basique bon c'est
vrai que ce soit c'est logique aussi
pour les Noirs
mais je veux dire
au premier coup alors
donc
tu peux pas
élimination il s'est dit à 4 et
j'attends mais oui c'est dur de
[Musique]
mais bon
ça par exemple
et là c'est juste pour comparer ah ok
c'est ça il veut se garder les tours sur
la 4e pour cut tout re 5
c'est hyper bien joué en fait à 4
en fait ça joue hyper bien oh
c'est monstrueux oh le level
ouais peut-être ça donne une idée d'un
moment de tourner deux torber de ton B5
j'en sais rien enfin
parce qu'en gros les blancs sont
contents
en fait tu es content de l'échange en B5
parce que deux fois plus mais en fait ce
tour c'est 5 elle est active elle nous
gêne si elle disparaît contre j'en sais
rien elle attend F4 et du coup il fait
quoi
B6 ouais c'est hyper logique
ah mais ok tu veux pousser deux G5 tour
H4 mais je sens que c'est pas si simple
à faire non
[Musique]
deuxième truc est-ce qu'il y a un moment
il peut vouloir fouiller 3 tours dessin
que une qualité un truc comme ça
[Musique]
et après
ça ça
veut vraiment de faire ça pour y arriver
et du coup peut-être même ranger trop on
n'a pas besoin de lui alors
au pire on s'en fout on n'est pas un
tempo-prime mais ça se trouve fait déjà
fou des deux ou pas d'ailleurs
[Musique]
on y arrive pas
ouais non s'il y arrive un jour
des quatre
[Musique]
et après tout F3 tourgers
au bout il y aura pas de victoire mais
il y a peut-être des idées ici ou là
pour pour faire craquer
je pense pas je pense qu'il va bien
défendre à rien j'ai peur que ce soit
trop facile mais il a du bol parce que
il a vraiment du bol Yann et justement
[Musique]
en fait là c'est hyper important de
commencer par H5
ok enfin bon
et du coup quand tu commences pas par H5
tu rentres dans cette finale de manière
forcée
ouais ouais il y avait un autre ordre de
coup genre
mais du coup tu rentres
ou pas
il a joué tous les mêmes coups mais dans
un autre ordre donc c'est pas bon
quand même donc parce que les gens
disent oui il y a pas de chance aux
échecs
et ça tient c'est que du bol en fait
100% bol là c'est gros bol en fait
[Musique]
ok ok
si tu l'as fait dans l'ordre allez
exceptionnelle la prépa mais ouais il a
inversé il se trouve que c'est pas si
grave jouer qui joue vite au début puis
après j'ai fait autre chose et puis
après j'ai regardé puis c'était la
finale donc j'ai eu un trou dans ce qui
s'est passé au mieux
[Musique]
mais ça c'est du bol quand un verre cet
après pas avec ça marche quand même
oui bah tu peux perdre sur le chantier
[Musique]
peut-être que jouer comme ça c'était bon
oui mais il a inversé en fait
il a pas joué dans le bon ordre même si
il savait dans tous les cas il a quand
même inversé ça change pas en fait
non mais a priorité très préparé
là-dessus
mais bon il s'est trompé de se tromper
[Musique]
parce que Ding en fait en gros il joue
ce système pour essayer de retourner
dans la position de des anglaises qu'il
a gagné plus ou moins quoi une structure
mais c'est 5
je sais pas quel est le verdict du truc
mais ça peut être super réputation à
cause de qui est promo 5 mais j'ai eu
des bons joueurs de jouer en fait avec
les Noirs donc peut-être qu'en fait ça
va mais quand moi j'avais un peu joué ça
il y a
7 ans en fait c'est ça que j'étais
content sans me le jouer quoi on dit ça
veut dire quoi inversé si ça tient quand
même à la fin peut-être ça peut être
considéré comme prépare aussi mais non
en fait ça marche quand même en fait je
sais pas comment dire c'est comme si tu
apprends à faire un truc
comme ça on t'explique que pour attaquer
au volley tu fais ton pas d'attaque
gauche droite gauche parce que tu es
droitier et que tu as tapé et ok bah tu
le sais tu t'entraînes tu sais faire
quoi puis je sais pas arrive le match tu
fais le pas d'attaque dans inversé je
trouve que ton smash passe quand même
mais que c'était mal placé que je sais
pas bah tu as de la chance que ça il
mais si tu le refais trop souvent la
plupart du temps ça ira pas quoi je sais
pas je te donne un exemple débile comme
ça mais juste un verset inversé bon bah
et ça passe quand même ouais mais là ça
passera pas là ça passer bon après faut
encore qu'ils finissent mais ouais
c'est comme si il faut mettre les œufs
avant la farine mais tu fais l'inverse
et que ça marche quand même
là ça
après ça peut craquer enfin là c'est
plus le mental qui peut être mis à
l'épreuve
les nerfs et tout ce qui s'ensuit quoi
avec la position de dépôt quoi
[Musique]
mais oui enfin moi aussi je pense que
normalement il va il va s'en sortir
sans trop suer d'ailleurs mais bon
ouais mais c'est l'avantage des coûts
donc si ça passe c'est pas de fin tu
contrôles plus rien mais si ça passe
c'est facile et puis on contrôle
[Musique]
une position ouais
mais en gros tu vois enfin je sais pas
genre la dernière partie Ding il avait
plus ou moins assis sur inversé il avait
une position ok égale mais bon faut bien
jouer il a su trouver les coups concrets
ou quoi mais
il était pas resté sans rien faire et je
sais pas si une époque il va arriver à
rester ou tu sais il va vouloir faire un
truc et peut-être tu peux te tromper
nous voulons plus un défaut d'yan de
vouloir être entrepreneur
parce que là apparemment je pense que tu
mets carrière Quino noir tu peux aller
faire une sieste
ou genre de d'individus
c'est vrai que défense comme ça passive
qui peut durer 10 20 30 40 50 coups
ça peut non mais ça peut le saouler je
vois pas qui qui rigole mais qui ça le
fait marrer
et Ben qui dit oui donne-moi les Noirs
là
il doit jouer des coups
de couvents et sont équivalent quoi mais
faut les jouer
de la pub aujourd'hui
prochaine pub dans 3 minutes Fab
[Musique]
parce que là ça va être une longue
finale un peu comme tu en as vécu
mais ça c'était le dernier coup j'ai
envie de dire où tu
sais le coup qu'on a tout de suite c'est
trop logique
bah tu défends tout tu mets tes pieds
sur noir
t'empêche un peu les percer un C5 qui
arriverait ou quoi je sais pas quand
mais bon et
voilà les solides
tu tiens bien la cinquième rangée
et
ok mais maintenant ça digne de montrer
si une petite idée mais il va essayer de
renforcer ouais c'est de ranger 3
je sais pas quoi là c'est un peu les
pièces et puis
laisser un truc une fois dans un sens
dans l'autre
5 peut-être un moment donné un truc quoi
comme tu le disais enfin je pense même
moi j'ai trop en premier
le fou en C2 et voir
déjà ce que Yann de toute façon tu
pourras refaire si tu as envie oui voilà
oui c'est une position où tu as au tote
tempo près même je veux dire les Noirs
comme ça donc lui il va il va il va
toucher à rien
bon après ça se trouve digne il va rien
faire et puis bon on est dans une
demi-heure mais
vous devez un point de retard il risque
rien que les blancs il doit jouer il
doit jouer même si
même si tu vois l'échec c'est pas grave
enfin tu joues et puis tu feras une dans
trois heures mais ouais
tu dois là
tu joues une heure deux heures trois
heures
je pense que au moins deux heures encore
cette position
si tu peux si tu peux maman s'il y a
plus rien qui est
plus baquis
si ça déforme bien tout le temps il y
aura nul voilà à tout de suite les amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez on est de retour je suis de retour
après la petite pause et bah du coup ça
n'a pas bougé depuis
tout à l'heure
on a la même
dans la même position Ding qui réfléchit
et ouais qui doit chercher des petites
idées mais qu'on me disait pas facile
pas facile donc les idées il peut
cumuler les idées d'aller attaquer
scorpion essayer de le prendre si peu
donc à base de rois G3 essaie de ramener
sous vers F1 un jour ou une tour
voir les deux tours mais bon c'est très
dur à réaliser parce que vous voyez bien
qu'il peut pas non plus faire ce qu'il
veut d'aller mailler parce que le fou
doit défendre à quatre peut-être les
toits un peu ce pion
donc bon on joue pas qu'un scout
d'affilée non plus sans que l'adversaire
ne joue
mais il y avait deux trois petites
possibilités s'arrêter peut-être
d'essayer d'amener une tour par ici un
moment et de jouer G5 pour peut-être
avoir du fougère ou quoi
peut-être une idée comme fousser deux
fois F5 à un moment pour échanger le fou
mais aller se diriger vers H3 peut-être
aller le prendre en même peut-être au
prix de 2 à 4 et aussi
dernier truc peut-être qui peut être
intéressant si on y arrive c'est
d'échanger cette tour
donc on se replaçant sur la colonne up
par exemple ou quoi avoir un petit tour
au 5 évidemment si on enlève cette
tournure c'est leur tour active on
libère un peu le fou on se gagne de la
place etc donc je sais pas peut-être
arriver à un moment à faire ça monter le
roi avoir tout le 5 donc ça c'est des
idées mais chaque fois bon ça c'est
c'est pas super concret ce que je vous
dis c'est juste voilà c'est des plans
qu'on peut avoir après arriver à le
faire marcher bon c'est pas simple moyen
d'échanger un pion c'est contre le pion
B pour faire un pur Basset demande Emma
Stone ah bah ça sera un rêve pour les
blancs évidemment de d'enlever ce pion
contre celui-là ou contre enfin voilà où
échanger
mais les normes vont pas te laisser
facilement faire ces cinq prises ils
sont là ils sont bien ancrés dans la
position et bon c'est 5
c'est 5 ouais bonne chance quoi
donc
ouais pas
[Musique]
facile enfin je veux dire a priori si
une hypo fait gaffe voilà mais bon tu
peux essayer essayer et peut-être qu'à
un moment il y a un petit craquage il y
a une idée pas vu par l'adversaire et on
va dire peut-être tour au 4 avec qui des
taux F5 ouais alors ça peut être une
idée bien sûr parce que tu te dis tiens
je fous le fou et pourquoi pas
ça peut être une option alors après ce
que c'est si grave on avait vu tout à
l'heure des idées avec tourage 6 comme
ça si on fait Tour Eiffel 5
il peut venir ici
nous contre cloué ça nous cloué et prise
prise donc on a échangé le tour mais pas
la plus active cela dit celui-là il est
moins bien défendu donc les trois G3
ça peut être une idée ça peut être une
idée ça d'aller prendre H3 alors après
bon bien sûr il va se venger sur
celui-là s'il veut
et à se comprendre si on regarde les
fous
[Musique]
bon probablement nul son échange les
fous parce que le problème sur tout
reprend c'est qu'on va se prendre sur le
coup d'après il va attaquer lui bah si
on ne redescend défendre il va
réattaquer lui bon son tourne en rond et
on répète soit on en donne un mais bon
finalement
passé mais il est loin d'être très
avancé ou quoi peut-être s'en fout prend
un quatre on conserve le fou
je sais pas on
va faire un tour
ouais bon après avoir un truc comme ça
le faut venir là ils ont quand même
assez très dangereux je suis pas
vraiment impressionné par les chances de
des blancs dans cette position mais bon
après de toute façon je sais pas si on
va trouver un truc enfin quand je vous
dis à priori c'est comme ça donc faut
essayer essayer par entendre dans un
truc trop forcé comme là peut-être qu'il
changerait trop vite pour peut-être
laisser une chance à adversaire de mal
jouer lui-même
détériorerait sa position peut-être
c'est ça la meilleure
stratégie entre guillemets
et l'autre avec trois attention chips de
patates enfin attention pas tellement
mais là dessus le Roi peut facilement
esquiver quoi quand tu es comme ça si
l'esquive là-bas il esquive rien parce
que tu le cloues donc c'est ça le
problème mais dans l'autre sens bon tu
fais rien de grave mais il te fait un F6
et tu as pas tout là donc au pire ce
qu'il y a pas de pas grave en fait quand
même position c'est que tu dis ah oui
tiens je fais fausse route je reviens
bonnes choses qu'il aille là et on a
juste répété une fois il y a pas mort
d'âme donc donc tu peux le tenter mais
voilà normalement c'est facilement
évitable
si j'ai ces cas pour prendre H3 ça ouais
ça c'est un bon échange
ça serait ça serait bien
quel coup on est oignon au 26 donc il
reste 14 coups ils ont beaucoup de temps
là ils ont beaucoup de temps pour
arriver au 41 il reste 14 coups pardon
pour genre 40-2 minutes mais ça fait
déjà un moment qui qui réfléchit digne
ça fait peut-être un quart d'heure déjà
donc il est large je n'ai pas une heure
donc
ok on va voir
est-ce qu'après à roi G3 est fou c'est
de
tu empêches pas un peu tôt c'est 5 ou
alors on peut accepter la finale après
alors j'ai pas tout capté la question et
tu veux dire moi j'ai trois bon disons
qu'il y en a pas rien
plus ils sont pas obligé de rien faire
mais là pour l'instant je on imagine si
stand donc genre ça
foulard on a dit bon j'arrive rien
et
on entend ça
et ça donne
ça donne qu'on perce option pour
l'instant en fait ça le problème donc
faut le préparer quoi là c'est en fait
un peu dans le désert
[Musique]
après sur conseil avec nos idées
est-ce que il peut éviter comme ça
bon c'est pas trop ce que j'accomplis
j'en mets cool
je joue des coups complètement au hasard
mais bon peut-être qu'à un moment force
de rien faire avec les noirs on va
trouver une manœuvre pour partir on
remet une pression là-dessus mais
franchement je vois rien de
[Musique]
dans un monde t'as pas une le faire avec
les blancs mais pourquoi faire en fait
je veux dire tu vois en fait le jour tu
le fais bah il te prend puis qu'est-ce
qu'on a accompli peinture
dans un coup il nous attaque celui-là
donc le jour tu fais ces 5 il faut
vraiment que tu es un enchaînement et
que tu coulisses par là-bas tu fasses
des trucs mais là
j'ai pas très envie de lui donner pour
lui donner quoi
est-ce que les gens ont le droit d'avoir
un échiquier avec eux dans la salle de
sport alors non pas du tout d'y aller
ils ont ils ont la télé de contrôle
l'écran mais non c'est un échiquier tu
peux bouger les pièces ça peut être trop
en fait aux échecs tu calcules tout
mentalement tu te projettes donc oui non
si tu peux bouger les pièces j'ai un
autre qu'on fait là l'analyse tu vois ça
c'est une grande aide donc non non c'est
complètement interdit
je suis d'accord moi j'ai trois c'est le
coup qu'on a envie de faire avec la main
même si on sait pas exactement ce qu'on
va en faire après on se dit il est pas
trop mal ici Laurent il est un peu plus
actif il jette un coup d'œil option il
protège celui-là donc ouais ça a l'air
ça a l'air logique
[Musique]
ça peut aller loin mais en fait ce qui
compte c'est bien évaluer la position
c'est du calcul 4 coups et que tu vois
que tu es mieux tu as peut-être pas
besoin de calculer 20 par contre si
après quatre coups on sait rien tu dois
pouvoir pousser donc des fois tu as des
ventes très longues qu'on peut voir
longtemps
[Musique]
même tu vois enfin j'en parlais hier
d'un mat enfin 25 coups
je le vois quoi enfin parce que c'est
dans de forcer mais ça va peut-être pu
être 35 couches je devrais aussi enfin
voilà après ce qui a de compliqué parce
que c'est très fouillis qui a beaucoup
beaucoup de variantes que tout se
ressemblent ça joue sur des petits
détails que machin bon mais quand c'est
une ligne droite tu peux tu peux y aller
quoi
il jouait facilement faire une ou doit
beaucoup réfléchir
bon il connaît pas mais sa position est
très solide donc il y a pas besoin de
jouer des coups de génie pour tenir mais
faut pas psychoter tout ça avec les
Noirs vouloir éviter des trucs
qui ont pas lieu d'être et d'un coup de
tout détérioré donc en tout casing a
joué le coup le coup attendu moi j'ai
trois voilà et c'est levé déterminé
donc bon voilà il va avoir des petites
idées de comment embêter en pratique son
adversaire et on va on va suivre ça quoi
une question marrante parce que dans les
toits normaux quelqu'un a déjà fabriqué
un échiquier par exemple avec des bouts
de mouchoirs ou autre pour s'aider à
réfléchir en bougeant les pièces dans
les toilettes alors j'en ai pas
connaissance
bah du coup si tu veux vraiment tricher
du coup
il aide informatique et quand même plus
utile quoi
mais
ouais ça peut être une
base de PQ exactement
comment est-ce que vous faites pour
retenir autant de parties de pro dans
vos têtes vous la regardez plusieurs
fois vous les classer par thème etc
[Musique]
je sais pas trop en fait je pense c'est
une habitude aussi quand tu joues tes
petits tu as lu des livres des parties
que tu les connais tu les as apprises
mais
un peu comme tu apprends des poèmes
quand tu es petit à l'école ou quoi et
voilà qui a fait ça demande plus un
effort surhumain à force quoi
parce que tu as pris cette habitude et
tu as ce type de mémoire là quoi
après il y en a qui vont mieux retenir
que d'autres ça on n'est pas tous égaux
face à ça il y en a qui doivent beaucoup
réviser revoir etc d'autres qui voient
un truc une fois
ça retenu donc
[Musique]
ouais tu vois ça dépend
parce que 75 blanche qui attaque par là
et défend celui-là est-ce que ça serait
gagnant je suis pas sûr pour autant ce
le jour on prendrait on perdrait à 4
mais ça donnera une option en plus vous
full 0 serait ouais c'est très cool bon
on a pas le droit mais
ici j'ai été sphérique il serait
peut-être pas mal le fou parce que tu
devrais passer là et puis tu rebondis à
par là-bas peut-être t'attaquerais lui
ou je sais pas enfin
ça pourrait être pas mal
tiens ma partie historique préférée
ah bonne question
bonne question en fait je sais pas
je vous ai de répondre mais il faut que
je réfléchisse en fait ça va pas sortir
tout seul comme ça
parce que
une comme ça
[Musique]
j'en sais rien peut-être le
non je sais pas en fait vous me collez
je veux dire une que j'aime bien c'est
la l'autre fois c'était la partie
castorov carpov en 90 dans l'espagnol
peut-être la 20e partie du match mais je
suis pas sûr que ça m'a préférée
préférée quand même juste assez marquant
elle est cool car super partie très
jolie
fisherburn impressionnante mais
peut-être trop tactique enfin trop
tactique il y a jamais trop mais
[Musique]
en fait je suis peut-être enfin c'est
pas tout je pense être plus
attiré ou plus impressionné par des
grandes conceptions stratégiques que par
des grandes ventes de calcul cela dit
très impressionnant aussi c'est pas le
problème et donc
Fischer campburn c'est très tactique
très tu vois il donne la dame il ramène
le fou enfin il joue une scène
incroyable c'est voilà on parle de
Castorama c'est un peu le même genre de
truc ou il fait à course au roi et il
donne ses tours ou quoi donc
[Musique]
c'est c'est très bien mais ouais genre
du carbone ziker ça me parle après le
truc c'est cool Dicker il est pas
défendu assez bien à mon sens
mais c'est important ce genre de partie
parce que on sait maintenant comment
traiter ce genre de position ça veut
dire ça reste passif l'enfermé
amélioration des pièces la Colonna le
jeune et le roi le jeu total sur
l'échiquier donc cool
donc esquiver
[Musique]
mais on va voir on va voir c'est quoi
l'idée sur tour des 6
il y a peut-être pas de grande idée en
fait on décide en fait on décide quoi
il a peut-être pas envie qu'on aille se
rentrer là-bas donc peut-être il va
faire ça
et réattaquer ce pion
[Musique]
voilà enfin après on peut le tenter de 6
ans c'est pas un mauvais coup pour les
blancs
non peut-être voilà une des parties qui
m'a le plus marqué on va dire le short
Timone
avec un thème pas vu
le roi H2 roi G3 jusqu'à H6
c'est pas la plus belle de l'histoire
non plus mais
voilà un truc comme ça quoi très
marquant très
bien pensé etc
de la tour sur la Colombie ça peut être
un plan alors ça peut tu pars tu tentes
pour aller là-bas
mais toujours pareil un jour on va
partir peut-être qu'elle elle peut venir
là
en fait on a plein d'idées mais je sais
pas si on peut en réaliser une ne
serait-ce que une quoi
qui est le genre qui m'a le plus
impossible lors d'un match bah
dire qu'il y a maîtrisé un match ou le
meilleur joueur de match en général quoi
après bon ça c'est des questions
subjectives tu vois je peux pas te dire
qu'il y en a un qui soit si
extraordinaire mais casse pas un
formatage c'était c'était costaud
c'était pas mal buvinique son approche
alors il en a perdu hein
donc c'est pas mal
mais la casse para for match je trouve
c'était pas mal les machines de carottes
c'était vraiment bien
bon alors bonding qui se replonge dans
une réflexion
l'aspect du jeu que j'ai le plus try
hard
je pense j'ai fait beaucoup de tactiques
combinaison quand j'étais petit
et je regardais les parties commentées
dans les livres etc donc ça c'était plus
ça j'ai pas travaillé comme un fou les
final ni les ouvertures
plus mieux de jeux
des choses comme ça
mais genre de l'histoire des échecs
selon bon dur à dire enfin tu vois je
peux pas trop te dire bon globalement ça
se joue entre Fisher kasporaf et Carlson
mais bon
tu vois peut-être que le plus doux
c'était même Philidor quoi enfin après
c'est dur de de dire quoi
mais sinon dans les joueurs récents et
voilà c'est
extraordinaire vraiment en avance sur
son temps fantastique
dominerait récemment
très bien et qui a son style très solide
très technique tu vas pas trop de défaut
dans son jeu quoi mais voilà après
plusieurs compères aussi les époques et
compagnie mais voilà Fisher c'est
peut-être le plus en avance sur son
temps quoi
le truc un peu révolutionnaire
et qui a vraiment écrasé un peu ses
contemporains
les autres ils ont dominé leur
contemporain mais j'affiche mes deux
fois 6-0 je pense pas qu'on le reverra
ça
c'est un genre d'échec ça serait qui
voilà la SS
car récemment c'est pas un joueur trop
en forme quoi
ok ok pourquoi pas je veux dire c'est
une option que que ni pour laisser donc
j'imagine qu'il va je Roger cette quasi
forcé puisque s'il vient ici on a un
nouveau notre clouage et donc on peut
jeter 5 ce qu'on cherche à faire depuis
tout à l'heure là on est très heureux
parce que on veut prendre et voilà il
peut même pas prendre son papillon prend
si on l'envoie la tour au coin bon bah
bien sûr c'est un grand accomplissement
donc à coup sûr n'est pas je range 7
alors après ce qu'on arrive à faire un
truc par ici ce qu'on va pouvoir tourner
dans le problème c'est qu'on a dit qui
est temps là qui est défendait
parce que c'est tout on va pouvoir faire
quelque chose sur le terrain manger en
fait je sais pas mais j'ai l'impression
que quand même ouais c'est une bonne
idée de Ding au moins c'est enfin un
truc un dépôt à jouer bon ben faire
ranger 7 sans surprise
et toi vite
ok tour à 8
bon je trouve ça logique ce qu'il fait
c'est je peux pas vous dire que ce soit
extraordinaire mais il est activé une
tour il s'est mis à 8 il bloque un peu
la tour à 5 à la défense de A7
il veut peut-être se dire tiens je vais
faire roi là puis je peux amener l'autre
tour et puis un moment j'ai peut-être le
mettre dans des dans des raisons de
maths enfin voilà si on joue du coup
d'affilée sur facile mais donc
on va voir
on va voir ce qui se passe mais il a une
petite idée il rend pas la tâche
forcément super facile à son adversaire
donc intéressant
du coup c'est vrai que c'est les Noirs
attendre trop je pense qu'on fait de
tour là tour là voilà et on est très
bien après il va pas attendre 50 coups
non plus peut-être que je torser 5 pour
directement attaquer celui-là mais dans
la SAT donc c'est pas une science simple
à prendre pourquoi donner à 7
ok peut-être ça pour les Noirs mais ça
je veux dire c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile donc dans C5 pas simple à faire
si
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire pour attendre
ça pour attaquer à 4
ok ça pour attaquer à quatre peut-être
probablement en fait
le pion donc il nous laisse rentrer si
on veut mais il nous dit ben je prends
si on prend on reprend on peut faire
tout reprend à 7 pour attaquer là-bas
mais on se fait échanger et ça
malheureusement je veux dire on va pas
gagner regarde ça et nul à venir quoi
on a un problème
[Musique]
on a un petit problème
et donc
[Musique]
c'est pas assez simple
passé simple qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
d'autre non mais ouais s'il fait fout
des sept
je crois que ça va tendre très très vite
vers les nuls
c'était pas un covidence je sais pas
visuellement tu vois ça me paraissait
rentrer mais en fait tu prends si
facilement celui-là et que tout
s'échange c'est cool est-ce qu'on peut
garder le four en vie
ça peut être une option
là tout d'un coup on est heureux on
attaqué cet à fond on peut prendre lui
ok cool oui donc là faut pas laisser
foulard donc disons ça
ça recommence les problèmes enfin les
problèmes
les oui nulle pas trop dur quoi
mais bon alors du coup ce qu'il faut
faire ça se passe comme ça c'est prendre
ça
et si je veux cette finale bon bah comme
je vous dis qui est nul mais mais bon
quoi faire quoi j'attends peut-être ça
prend un chèque et là je me fais bouffer
lui
j'aime plus de temps de plus en arrière
je vais prendre lui il va prendre lui
bon
ouais si c'est ça le scénario
donc ouais 17 possible pour pour mes
pots et probablement très bon
et
j'ai l'impression que c'est pas trop dur
parce qu'en fait tu sais pas trop quel
coup jouer avec les noirs du coup
je veux dire tu as pas envie de toucher
assez de tour pour donner à ça
donc torcer 5 ça paraît pas séduisant
son papier
torrent là-haut pour échanger bah on
échange on va gagner H3 donc t'as pas
envie non plus donc cette turbo bouge
pas c'est de t'en bouge pas ton roi
ici je sais pas enfin ça change rien
elle est blancs peuvent commencer ce
genre de plan donc à vrai dire faut des
7 c'est le seul coup dispo qui fait
quelque chose
qui va aller chercher spion et qui a
l'air transposer dans une finale facile
donc voilà grosse probabilité qui rentre
dedans
Thor C5 peut-être déjà ok
mais en gros c'est pas l'échange que les
Noirs ont envie de faire je veux dire ça
ça se tient peut-être toujours parce que
ils ont spi on baisser qui tient nos
deux pions passés ils ont des pièces
actives etc mais ça c'est moins simple à
annuler que que la finale de tour qu'on
a quand on regarde après fodes donc
souvent en fait c'est comme ça aux
échecs tu vois tes options tu vois qu'en
fait dans ces 5 possibles fouder cette
possible tu calcules les lignes et tu
les compares et en gros bah tu compares
ces positions là
donc celle-ci ou tu as un pion de moins
mais que tu as pas envie de voir
peut-être les blancs un jour il va faire
à 5 d'échanger ça tu dis ouais c'est
peut-être possible leur avion passé ça
va être chiant machin bon ok tu dis si
je dois le faire je fais mais et tu
compares à ça
qui est plus ou moins forcé
bon mais ça c'est vachement plus simple
c'est le même genre de finale sauf que
eux ils sont doublés au lieu d'être
comme ça et on a encore échangé un
fournitoires donc on a une tour active
qui pose des problèmes
si les gens veulent prendre ça nous on
prend celui-là et on va rebouffer ces
trois et même s'il est blanc défendent à
3 on reste avec un pion de plus mais
vous savez qu'en fait les deux
contraints sur la main ça fait nul quoi
donc
on va pas vraiment arriver à faire à
faire grand chose alors après bon on
peut toujours tester voilà je crois
courir là-bas
mais bon ça je veux dire objectivement
quasi aucun espoir quoi
donc voilà
faut des cinq dans cette variante alors
faut des 5 je l'avais pas forcément
possible parce que ce qu'on avait dit
section de faire faut des seins qu'on
doit faire ça et ça donc ce qui a l'air
cool mais malheureusement il revient
nous re proposer l'échange et même nous
l'imposer parce qu'il touche la tour à 8
au passage donc je peux même plus
esquiver maintenant je dois prendre il
prend
et plus ou moins la même chose
donc voilà pourquoi je trouve des sets
pas mal
ça m'a l'air
il peut très bien partir sur torcet 5
parce que il va pas aimer la finale de
tout résultat
etc je peux pas deviner à 100% mais bon
retour de
je suis pas tombé sur la partie la plus
passionnante
pas de chance tellement de choses à dire
sur celle précédente mais là ça tient
bien à côté Yann il a réussi à faire ce
qu'il fait pas toujours c'est garder la
position
ouais j'ai fait marcher les turbines sur
la partie il y aura des choses à dire
sur le
pour l'ouverture un peu et
là il dit quoi il faut des sacs ou là il
dit tout il dit tout mais justement
quand il y a du choix c'est plus dur
tu as bien expliqué tout à l'heure
on n'est pas pas très très bien
c'est bizarre ici j'ai l'impression
d'être coupé mais pas du tout mais pas
du tout coupé
moi je voyais plutôt sa seule idée pour
gagner avec les Blancs c'était de jouer
pour un fou c'est deux fois F5 tout à
l'heure c'est ce que je pensais mais
après bon évidemment c'est égalité
disons ça ça
tourne à 8 mais bon il y a trop de
on arrive pas à aller attaquer
c'était quoi ton coup favori ici
[Musique]
et rentrer là-dedans
je sais pas si on va là où là d'abord
[Musique]
mais je trouve l'autre plus simple mais
ça peut-être que il est content quand
même je préfère
[Musique]
la calculer c'est pas mal
ah je pensais qu'il irait peut-être le
enfin
longtemps qui peut avoir des fois c'est
genre de final ou tu as toujours le
pirement
et je sais pas ça
calcule bien sa ligne elle du plat voilà
[Musique]
je sais pas non plus enfin non mais
c'est pas
quand même
dans 5
comment il veut faire des
après
le tour d'abord
d'ailleurs on peut faire tour C4 mais on
peut aussi taper à 4 souvent
est-ce qu'on peut ici vous B3 avec les
détours C4 je sais pas
probablement Pierro va se retrouver avec
un deux contre un mais pas difficile en
fait mais tous ces cas j'aime bien aussi
si on peut après
temps de s'en aller
le roi est bizarrement placé là en
quatre même probablement un coup comme
tour B3
ça a l'air d'être
une maison
il reste
fous aussi à tour des trois
fautes
la tour de s'activer de l'autre côté
mais
un joli
il avait peut-être
quand on échange les fous au mieux on va
se retrouver avec la finale tout régih
par exemple si tu fais tourner
pour ces quatre
tours C6 je pense
mieux on va se retrouver avec tout et
puis on GH comme tout et puis en bref
[Musique]
on fait un coup
on fait ça en échange et voilà ce genre
de finale et ça c'est vraiment nul très
facile beaucoup plus facile que la
partie précédente avec les cavaliers
donc ouais bah bien calculé de la part
de Yann Le Petit le petit tour des sept
fou B3 là
temps passive c'est vrai que s'il a ça
donc c'est vrai qu'avec le calcul on
peut très bien comprendre le couteau C5
on se dirige vers une nulle rapide
alors il faut pousser à combien les
turbinets ça dépend des positions en
fait ici tu as pas besoin d'aller en
grosse profondeur parce que
beaucoup de pièces donc on voit mais
dans les ouvertures il faut pousser pour
qu'il trouve le meilleur coup donc le
mieux c'est d'avoir
plus que les que tes adversaires en fait
c'est un peu une guerre à l'armement
c'est-à-dire si tu es en profondeur 50
que tu trouves que c'est bien tu vas
voir le j'aime à 26 plus qui va être en
profondeur 55 dans toutes les positions
quand le prochain il sera en profondeur
60 etc et des fois ça change beaucoup
enfin que à 13h50 il dit que c'est bien
et que en fait c'est complètement égal
donc
il y a plus de limites en fait forcément
que si
le plus puissant possible il va te
donner forcément les meilleurs coups
perso tu as été très genre choqué par
des lignes qui allaient qui avaient déjà
regardé et que tu savais que ça allait
bien aujourd'hui et tu mets autre chose
et d'un coup par exemple aujourd'hui il
y a 10 ans
augmente leur capacité de
d'évaluation
comme Kevin il est plus grand il voit le
chat
alors qu'on a pas regardé
donc pas mal aussitôt recettes parce que
le fou B3 il faut promettre
donc ça marche plus
et mes tours des 6 maintenant
probablement
il se réactive il attaque notre fou
on va de quel côté son idée c'est
peut-être faut tourner F3 tour des trois
tours
sont liés
donc regardons après tout recettes
réfléchissons un petit peu ça pose un
problème qu'on a pas encore résolu
[Musique]
ça pose un problème qu'on a pas encore
résolu
quand même
est-ce qu'on est content d'échanger une
tour par tour aussi
alors
je peux prendre
[Musique]
H3 c'est notre problème donc ça on va le
laisser mais si tour 7
[Musique]
on reprend et tout 3 et là on a un vrai
problème on défend un peu tout le monde
et on va prendre F3 donc ça ça va pas
pour les blancs
va falloir attaquer ces trois tours
C3
on va le montrer hop donc on en face le
football partir et on se fait attaquer
comme ça
donc c'est un coup assez malin qui pose
des petits problèmes
F1 on a du fouet peut-être
pour une E3 tours
mais F3 encore
voir il peut y avoir du faux B3 aussi là
mais dans les idées attention il reste
plein de coups il y avait même du tout
F3 incroyable OK
donc ouais il serait organise et là il
faut être précis avec la noix on est
dans le chat que CC repose sur hc6
donc il se prépare enlever le four en
avance ok alors ça c'est un coup
difficile alors on va le retirer parce
que c'est pas genre nous on l'avait pas
dans les flocons proposés non mais on
peut la voir mais c'est pas un coup tu
as vraiment envie de faire parce que
déjà ouais c'est pas
[Musique]
et on va aller vers une finale avec deux
pions contre sur l'elroit on préférait
échanger les fous d'abord quand même
alors si c'est un des seuls coups c'est
pas facile ça pose une vraie question et
tout recettes
c'est un bon coup
c'est pour avoir les tours c'est
vraiment un beau
vous aussi ouais faut aussi c'est un
coup aussi mais pour E3
après faut aussi soit peut-être ici tout
rushi attention
donc là peut-être tu vois peut-être mais
pas agréable
heureusement mais pas ouais ouais là on
comprend il va réfléchir je pense qu'il
va réfléchir une bonne dizaine de
minutes ici
je n'ai pas je pense qu'il a envie de
trouver un truc en force non vu comme il
a joué avant non mais il va trouver tous
ces six par défaut peut-être
mais il a pas envie
et ça on peut le faire ici l'ordinateur
peut-être qu'il donne davantage pour
personne mais il y a un pion en plus
pour les blancs donc il y a un clair
avantage blanc c'est parce que l'ordi
voit
25 30 coups d'avance
niveau que ça suffit pas donc c'est nul
mais nous on regarde à quelques coups
qu'on voit qu'on est très proche de la
nul il faut descendre et peut-être
et si maintenant mais est-ce qu'on
aurait pas dû à tourner d'accord ça il
peut faire par exemple mais foie F3
attention
à foie F3 ici qui passe encore de vrai
problème parce que faut prendre tout
reprendre
tout reprend C3 on clou mais en fait on
clou pas tour E3 F7
on aimerait jouer
en premier on a on a
vrai vrai question je crois qu'il a joué
dans ces 6 niveaux
par défaut on trouve le tour C6 mais
après on reprend H3
du coup on rapproche 3 c'est quoi c'est
fou
[Musique]
alors si c'est fouet fin c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'il a trouvé parce que fouet
fin roi G3 mais bon c'est trois de toute
façon
on peut pas attaquer directement non non
il va jouer sur approche 3 il va jouer
des 5 ou 6
regarde ça
on a du mal à
pouvoir avancer ce pion h
peut-être x 2
encore bosser un petit peu
mais il peut y avoir du Fou des 5
touches on a ouais
on a un problème de roi
dommage parce que si on a le temps de
consolider
si on échange une tour ça nous aide pas
trop trop trop
il reste des activités
assez caché par la tour et le pion qui
avance en plus
repart attention
deux choses l'une
le roi est très faible en fait même
quand on prend le pion S3 on n'arrive
pas à
c'est chiant ce rock et en plus le fond
c'est jamais le mettre s'il a pas de
pion pour le pour l'accrocher
[Musique]
de résoudre un peu tous les tous les
soucis
mais bon il rapproche son c'est logique
enfin j'ai quoi d'autre de
sa mère pas la sécurité du roi
trop longtemps et tu te fais prendre
celui-là tu as d'autres genre de souci
quoi
et non mais là les deux derniers coups
très jolie des deux joueurs
des coupes pas facile mais après c'est
des championnats du monde
c'est championnat du monde donc on
attend de telles coups mais ouais joli
passe d'armes
joli partie d'ailleurs depuis le début
j'ai trouvé bon
à part le petit la petite erreur de
dépôt dans l'ouverture et le j'ai trouvé
que Ding a joué un peu vite la séquence
entre le 15e et le 20e
[Musique]
mais rentrer en force dans cette finale
là
faut faire attention aux énergies ouais
dur
on parle de fou d'eux dans le chat mais
le problème c'est que d'échanger les
fous parce qu'on disait si tu es changé
le fou après on échange une paire de
Tours et la finale devient très facile
comme ça et ouais
les Blancs ne sera pas faible mais c'est
plus le problème maintenant c'est que
eux ils vont disparaître
par exemple
[Musique]
du coup on doit se décaler avec les
Blancs sinon on va être clouer
et hop et voilà donc ça c'est le genre
de finale donc de contraintes sur la
même aile
c'est très facile de
monter très loin arriver avec un pion
jusqu'ici facilement mais les échecs
c'est un jeu très annulant donc des fois
même avec un vrai avantage
matériel on peut pas on peut pas
convertir
enfin c'est très annulant à part sur ce
match c'est vrai que là
mais dans les finales comme ça ouais
et quand je parlais de la faiblesse du
roi blanc évidemment c'est pas pour
perdre mais c'est c'est pour
il est faible et ça permet au noir de
faire nul quoi simplement
parce que souvent on va perdre un pion
soit on va devoir échanger des pièces
là il y a plus vraiment de pièges on est
d'accord elyséum mais bon courage C6 va
le trouver quand même
[Musique]
ici on n'arrive pas à organiser une
défense sur le roi blanc
parce que si le roi va vers H4 souvent
il va y avoir des fous des 5 ok on va
prendre déjà en C3 mais il va y avoir
des fous des seins et tout H6 échecs des
idées à base de ça si on part sur G2 il
va y avoir du Fou des seins qui
avec le clouage et si on part vers F2
il va venir nous attaquer à deux par
trois par exemple notamment et on a un
problème et on voit là on a un problème
du roi dans toutes ces variantes il est
coupé
ne vous inquiétez pas pour la pendule de
Ding il va pas la perdre celle-là
la turbinade de Tours 7 5 ouais mais si
on échange des pièces ils ont reste avec
le même problème mais bon on peut le
voir vite fait un tour cette 5 oui c'est
pas mal en fait peut-être
on n'a pas prisé d'ailleurs par hasard
le nouveau le fameux la fameuse idée
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure le truc de
n'est pas
ouais ça a l'air d'être vraiment trop
drôle
ouais plus trop
et en plus tout ce qu'on vous montre
c'est jamais d'une forcée encore
d'autres options qui vont aussi
alors sur présage 3 fois 6 fois 2 il
faut baisser 5
peut-être mais bon ça va changer a
priori
alors déjà faut choisir on met le roi
là j'imagine tu vas aller à la hausse
non c'est toujours ce truc
et après bon même fou dessin avec la
tour irailleur mais ça a pas l'embêter
plus que ça donc je sais tôt
[Musique]
avec cette idée de
l'attaque du roi
belle défense quand même
branding du coup il réfléchit à essayer
de trouver peut-être le truc le plus
tricky en pratique mais là il a plus la
plus trop d'idée je trouve que c'était
bien ce qu'il a tenté mais ok quand
c'est drôle c'est drôle hein
[Musique]
du coup bonne défense de dépôt en fait
quand il y a peu de pièces comme ça
c'est pas simple
pas le genre de position qui espérait
digne avant avant la partie non il
voulait avec beaucoup de pièces avec
beaucoup de possibilités même pas
forcément mieux pour lui mais ça joue
longtemps et ouais peut-être le premier
jour où il a pas vraiment trouvé de
faille même si il était pas si loin mais
[Musique]
et ça va être la petite tactique
il préfère tout reprendre 5 et le fameux
faux et il va dire oups la pièce oups
m'en fous
bon il faut prendre a priori ouais parce
que là si on prend pas si on bouge le
foot on reprend C3
qui va protéger A4 donc on peut pas tout
donner non plus prise échecs il va
prendre en fait il va tenter ça ouais
mais juste
et la petite finale tant attendue
c'était il y a des chances ça à la suite
ça va être ça va finir avec tour de
pions contre tourpillon
et ça va pas être joué
5 là
j'ai bien défendu à demain tu vas voir
les Noirs demain on sera tout de
défendre tu vois une petite espagnole
le tweet sur la Drôme partir
et au nom de
il se rapproche de
se rapproche du Graal il y a l'important
ça c'est des quasiment une partie
décisive enfin pas encore il reste
quatre parties mais
plus ça c'est graines plus rapproche et
puis chaque fois qu'il a les blancs
demain ça va être une grosse grosse
partie donc rendez-vous 11h demain 11h
pour pour une partie qui peut être
décisive oui ce n'est pas gagné je pense
qu'il va encore parce que il souffre un
peu quand même un tout petit peu avec
les Noirs il sait qu'il peut souffrir
donc il va il va tout faire pour pour
pousser comme comme il le fait si bien
s'il arrive à s'en sortir ouais il va
il trouvera de nouvelles idées
[Musique]
le petit fouet
j'ai cinq tours G40
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà les pubs qui sont partis au
meilleur moment Fab juste avant la fin
mais là ça va finir
au moins d'une minute
[Rires]
en fait on est décalé ouais on est un
petit peu
bon bravo
[Musique]
ok bah voilà on a tout dit
on prend le petit récap et puis on se
retrouve demain alors merci Fab merci
Baky c'est bien tombé le baquet ciao
tout le monde ciao ciao à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]